- You know how when you read
manga, you can pick the pace
you're reading at, right?
So everyone has a different pace, right?
- Which reminds me.
- Yeah?
- Speaking of pacing, and poop, pooping.
(men chuckle)
(tape whirring)
- What made you bring this up?
- Oh, because I heard
poop and I heard pacing.
(men laughing)
- I did not say poop.
(relaxing music)
Hello and welcome to another
episode of Trash Taste.
I'm your host for today, Garnt.
Joining me today again are
the boys and who is this
sitting next to me?
Do you want to introduce
yourself to the world?
Who are you?
- It's me, Daidus.
(men laugh)
- You have to do that.
- What is this?
What was that?
- I've been abusing this a lot.
Every time someone wants
something from me, I'm like.
- What does this mean?
- What does abusing it mean?
- I don't know.
- Isn't that, like, "What's
up?" In Hawaii or something?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
- It's like, "Aloha."
- Is it actually?
- Yeah, they're like, "Aloha."
- I just like that, I like it
'cause I don't have to speak,
I just.
(men laugh)
- What are you, mute?
- Well, since moving to
Japan, I've been doing
this lately, like.
(men laugh)
- It's like, "Yes, I understand."
- Is that just to nod to other people?
- Yeah, yeah, no matter what,
if I'm passing by somebody,
they see me, I'm like.
- Even if you don't know them?
- It's automatic at this point.
- Why?
- You just do that to everyone?
Everyone you pass on the street?
- No, only if they, I
don't know, they're like-
- Make eye contact?
- If it's a narrow hallway
or they make eye contact, I'll be like.
it's just automatic, I don't know.
Actually, it was crazy, I saw the,
I saw this lady on the phone.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And she's talking to
her cell phone like this.
Like this.
And she was going.
- [Connor] Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I was like, "That
was the craziest thing
I've ever seen in my life."
Why are you cradling it like a baby?
(men laugh)
- Bowing on the phone.
- Yeah, she's bowing on
the phone constantly.
- I've seen fucking salary
men do full like 90 degree,
full on bowing on the phone.
- Why?
- Honestly, I bow by
habit as well sometimes.
When I end a conversation,
I just have to bow.
- It's just like a knee-jerk reaction.
You just have to do this.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Even if I'm on the phone, I'm like.
- Yeah.
- They can't see me bowing right now.
- You can't say it.
It is physically impossible
for you to say, "Hai"
On the phone without moving your neck.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You can't just go, "Hai, hai, hai."
It's that vein-popping meme,
it's just, "I'm not gonna bow."
- Try not to bow challenge.
- It's a wonderful combo,
when you say, "Hai" You gotta.
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly.
- It goes with the neck, bro.
The neck muscle, it activates.
- I guess the reason why
you are impressed by bowing
is 'cause you just moved here.
- I mean, for our audience
who do not know who you are,
do you wanna explain
what you do on YouTube?
Who you are?
- Yeah, I'm a loser that
animates my life, I guess.
And then when I'm bored
of animating my life,
I do fun, random stuff that, you know?
- Like what?
Like what?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, what's the random
stuff you do?
- Game?
- No.
- Yes it is.
- Yes it is,
what do you mean?
- Well, I make little, so most time
I'm a Story Time animator,
but you know, I don't really
call myself that.
- You gotta keep the mic
pretty close to you, by the way.
- Oh, hello.
- You gotta eat the mic.
- [Joey] You gotta cradle it like a baby.
- Yeah, cradle it like a baby
and bow to it, bow to it.
- So you make other things?
- Yeah, I mostly make
just animations basically.
And then...
And that's about...
(all laugh)
- That was the most funny pause.
- Yeah, oh yeah. (chuckles)
- Yeah, that's about it, I just animate.
- And you're a member of
GeeXPlus now, aren't you?
- I am.
- Yeah, yeah.
How's it feel to be in Japan?
Because you just moved
here like, three weeks ago?
I forgot.
- [Joey] Not even a month.
A month ago, right?
- Three weeks ago or something.
- I can't remember, man.
- The time goes fly by fast
because I'm just building
furniture constantly.
(men chuckle)
- That's how it always is though.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then we're going
to the Japanese bank
and then they try to
give me a bank account
and I'm just sitting
here and then there's two
Japanese ladies just translating.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And then they're going back and forth.
And then it literally, I
got there at like, 8:00 AM.
And then went all the way
'til like, I think we
got out like, 7:00 PM.
- [Joey] Jesus.
- The bank plus the phone.
The phone too.
- Oh yeah, getting the phone.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I did that in one day.
- It do be like that.
- It literally took like,
I don't know.
- An entire day.
- Entire day.
- Yeah, an entire day.
- I was like, "This is..."
And I felt useless too
'cause I can't speak
the language yet, so I was just like...
I was just sitting there, they
was translating and then...
- How was applying for
a visa to come here?
- Oh, it was a, it was death.
(men chuckle)
- When did you start?
'Cause I think I basically was, you know,
I'd been teasing them all
about how fun Japan is,
and they'd be like, "Oh."
'Cause originally you-
- I hate this guy.
He'd post pictures of food
and stuff, and I'm like,
"I hate this fucking guy."
(men laugh)
- I've played league with
Emily and Daidus a lot,
and then we obviously do our
videos together, and you know,
originally you were gonna
come to Japan in April, 2020
for vacation, right?
- Oh, you're gonna bring
this up, okay.
- Give them the backstory?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- The lore, I like the lore.
- So you were gonna
come in 2020 with Emily
to come and just hang out and visit,
and obviously as we all
know what happened in April.
- Right at the start, yeah.
- And then we were like, "Don't
worry, it'll open up soon.
It'll open up soon."
It never opened up.
So it got to like, what?
2021?
mid 2021, I was like, I mean-
- Just waiting for you, bro.
- "You interested in coming here?"
- No, actually, no.
I think two years ago you said,
"Do you wanna move there?"
You asked me, and I was
like, I think I asked Emily,
I was like, "Well, I feel
like we should test Japan
to see if we like it first,
so we're gonna visit."
- 'Cause I've heard that
you've never left the States
before moving here to Japan.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
I've only been to Canada and Florida.
I live in Maine.
- Oh, that's two different
countries, right?
- I like the way you said,
"I've been to Canada,
a different country, and Florida,
also a different country."
- It is, it is.
(men laughing)
- So Japan was a very
big jump then, I guess?
- Yeah, yeah, so, well,
my mom's Cambodian.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Half Chinese or whatever.
- Yeah.
- But she never bought me to
Cambodia 'cause she's always
afraid of dangers.
It's dangerous over there, so I'm like,
well, I guess I never got to visit ever.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Literally ever.
I don't know why.
- I guess you're close
now though, you could visit.
- Cambodia's just a stone throw away now.
- Yeah, I hope it's more safe over there.
- So Jesus, you just,
you flew the coop then,
because you went from not basically going
out of North America to
fucking moving to Japan,
just like that.
- Not even visiting Japan.
- Not even visiting.
You are now just living here.
- Well, first of all,
the borders were closed
forever and ever, and
ever, and ever and ever.
We were waiting literally
a year or whatever long.
I was dying in my basement, I was rotting.
There's nothing to do there.
I was bored as hell in my mom's basement.
My mom did my laundry.
(men laugh)
She cooked for me.
- That's an important point.
- I was just like, I was
just chilling too hard
to the fact that like, I
didn't wanna do anything,
I was just.
- Right, right, right.
- Yeah, I was just playing video
games, I'm gonna be honest.
- Yeah.
- I was just rotting away.
And then, you know, finally the
borders opened up, and then,
oh yeah, I also gained,
I gained like, 50 pounds,
and then I lost 20 pounds,
but then I regained 20 pounds
and then I lost 30 pounds or something.
So I've been yo-yoing.
- That just sounds like
adulthood in general.
- No, it was just, it was just COVID.
(Garnt chuckles)
- That just sounds like
metabolism, you know?
- Adulthood is like gaining a few pounds
and you're just like, "Fuck,
I need to go on diet."
And you diet good for a
month and you're like,
"Yes, I've lost those
pounds, I can keep going."
You don't keep going, and
then you gain the pounds back
and you're like, "Fuck,
I should diet again."
And then you start dieting,
and then it's like a yo-yo
between the same 10 pounds or whatever.
You just never win.
- Yeah, it's very sad because,
I think before 2020 happened,
you know, the whole COVID
thing happened, you know,
when I was gonna visit Japan.
And I was at my peak, I was pretty skinny.
I was at the, you know, I was
comfortable in my own body.
I was like, "I'm gonna
put myself out there."
And then COVID hit and I was like, "Oh."
And then I just became a
basement dweller again.
(men chuckle)
- So you decided just to fucking get out
and just do something, just
get a change, basically.
- So I've been yearning to,
I used to live in New York during college
for art college.
- Right.
- And that was essentially
like throwing myself out there,
into the wild.
- Right.
- And I missed that feeling of
just being thrown to a wild.
- Trying to figure stuff out?
- Not even, I just like
the fact that it's like,
"What is this thing?"
And it piques, it piques
your brain, you're like,
"Wait, this is something different."
And then, in Maine, or just United States,
any state you go to, it's not really
that much different.
- Yeah.
- Except Florida.
- Except Florida, and
then you'll get shot.
(men laughing)
Then die.
But yeah, that's what I like about Japan.
The whole, you have an
umbrella and you put it in
the slot thing and it
just, and it takes off.
- Oh, you lock the umbrella?
- It has a bag.
- Oh, the bag thing.
- It's a bag!
And I was like,
"I've never seen this."
- The umbrella condom.
- Yeah!
I was like, "This is crazy."
And also the workers in America.
Every time you go like,
let's say 7-Eleven.
First of all, you got a bunch
of druggie guys over there.
What you call them, homeless
people or something?
(men chuckle)
- Yeah.
I mean, I guess, I dunno.
I dunno what the politically
correct term for that is, but.
- I'm pretty sure druggie guys is not
the political correct term.
- Sketchy guys.
- Sketchy, yeah.
- Sketchy.
- Sus guys.
- Especially in New York.
Every time I leave at
3:00 AM in the morning,
I'll always get pursued by, you know?
- Yeah, that sounds terrifying.
- Pan handler.
- Yeah.
- And then they'll follow
you into the store and then,
and then they, you know, I'm like,
"Well, I would give you money,
but if I gave you money,
that means I would have to give $1,
no, I'd have to give 50 bucks every day
because you literally
get begged that much."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So I'm like, I don't
know, it's just nonstop.
- Right, right, right.
- So anyway, so, the gas station story.
Go back to Japan, right?
Also, by the way, the workers in 7-Eleven
or wherever they are, they look like
they don't wanna be there.
They look sad.
- What, in America or Japan?
- In America.
- Oh, okay.
- I like that though.
- Yeah, I mean, it's pretty
chill 'cause you're just like,
you go in.
- I don't think you're
paid enough to also then
have to pretend to be happy about it.
- I mean, to be fair, it's
kind of the same way in Japan
as well.
- They pretend to be happy, and I'm like,
"You don't get paid enough."
But sometimes they're chill though.
- Yeah, yeah.
- They're sometimes chill.
- Sometimes they're chill.
Yeah, yeah.
- Sometimes.
- Well, there was one time.
Actually, I think this happened
when I just came to Japan.
I went to a 7-Eleven.
I went to get a beer.
A Strong Zero or whatever,
and then it wasn't scanning.
The guy ran.
He ran because it wasn't scanning.
He ran to the fridge, and
then he ran back, like.
(panting)
(speaks Japanese)
And I was like, "You
don't need to do that."
(Garnt laughing)
- And he's bowing and stuff, apologizing.
I'm like, "This is so sad."
I like the service you're
giving me, but I feel bad
that you have to feel like
you have to act this way.
- Yeah.
- But that's the thing
though, right?
Japan's standard for customer
service is so insanely high
that there is probably some
Japanese guy or girl out there
who would complain, being like,
"Come on, hurry up."
- Yeah, yeah.
- It makes me sad a little
bit, but at the same time,
I get good service, you know?
- Yeah, exactly.
(men laugh)
- It ain't my problem.
- Sometimes the service is
so good that it's imposing.
I'm just like, "I don't need the service
to be this good, bro.
You can chill" You know?
- Sometimes they do it so
good that next time you go
to the same place.
like when you go to a ryokan, right?
Sometimes when you get
there, they welcome you
like you're a king, dude.
- [Daidus] Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
- They take your bags,
they're looking after you,
and then other times you'll
go to another ryokan,
you'll be like, "I hope they
do it, but I won't expect it."
And then you get disappointed
when they're like,
"All right, well, what do you want?"
(Garnt laughs)
- When you do find that
one guy that doesn't care,
you're just like, "What is this?
This is rare."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It completely warps
your perspective on it,
even though you go
anywhere else in America
and it's just normal.
- It's normal, yeah.
- It's just like, it's
warped my perception of,
you know, what I find is good service
and what even stands out to
me, 'cause I remember, I was,
'cause I was in England last week.
I remember just going to a
normal restaurant, you know?
And it was such a small thing.
Because I was so used to
just the Japanese service
being as polite and as,
you know, soft as they can.
So I remember, it was just,
I went to a restaurant
and then I asked for the bill, right?
And it was just such a small thing.
They slammed it down on the
table and said, "It's a."
They slammed down the
table and said, "It's £50."
I was just like, "Well,
that was a bit aggressive."
You know what I mean?
It surprised me because I
was so used to, you know,
Japanese service, just bringing it to you.
- They'd probably be like,
"£50" (speaks Japanese).
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly, right?
Exactly, right?
I didn't even get a please,
you know, or something,
or you know, or thank you.
"£50."
- That is quite odd even
for the UK to be fair.
- Really?
I don't know, 'cause I've,
it's been so long since
I've been to the UK
that I'm just like, "Am I an
asshole for thinking that was
a bit aggressive?"
- Normally they don't say
the price out loud, right?
Am I crazy?
- Oh, they kind of just
like, "Here's the bill."
- They just give it to you.
- What's interesting, they
bring the bill to you in the UK,
but in Japan I noticed
you always have to go up.
- It depends on the restaurant.
- Oh, really?
I haven't been to a single one
where they gave you the bill.
- Yeah, for some reason,
sometimes you have to pay
at the table, so they bring you the bill.
- Normally the fancier it is
or the more European it's trying to be,
you pay at the table.
- Yeah, you pay at the table.
- So then if it's just like-
- But if it's a Japanese
chain, then you can pay-
- I'm waiting for that moment, bro.
- Really?
- Yeah, hasn't happened yet.
- I'll take you to a place.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I know a place.
- I know a place.
Best Italian food in Japan.
- Yeah, normally if it's
Japanese food, then you'll pay
at the till, but if you go
to a more westernized place,
then they try to, I guess
embrace foreign culture.
- It's fine 'cause some of the restaurants
will actually have like a thing that says,
"Pay at the table."
- Yeah.
- Well, if they want to
embrace foreign culture,
they should do tips.
I'm just kidding. (chuckles)
- I wish they did.
- Bro, honestly-
- You don't want tips. (chuckles)
- No, but how good the
service in Japan is,
sometimes I wish I could-
- I don't want American tips.
I don't want 20% of the fucking bill tips.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Hold the fucking phone.
- That's why we don't eat out as much.
- [Connor] I don't blame you.
- I noticed the grocery store,
if you live in the city,
the grocery store is more
expensive than eating out,
which is like...
- Yeah, Japan is one of the rare countries
where eating out's actually cheaper.
- It's so weird.
- Last time we said that, we
got some people who were like,
"How dare you say that?
It's not true at all."
- [Daidus] Well, if you
live in a city, I guess.
- Certain things are cheaper,
certain things are more expensive.
Obviously if you go to,
you know, (indistinct)
and get a pasta,
you get this much for
like, 300 yen, then yeah,
you should make your own pasta.
But that's pasta.
Like if you want a ramen,
you can't make your own ramen
from home.
- Yeah, exactly.
- It's gonna be so many ingredients.
- The melons are like $300, why?
- Have you tried one of them?
- It's like this and it's 300.
- It's 'cause some guy rubs it for hours.
He's just massaging it.
- What'd you mean, have you tried one?
- He's not even joking.
- No, no, no, no, no.
I'm just asking, have you tried it?
- No, no, no.
- It's not worth it, it's not worth it.
- It's not worth it.
'Cause I actually saw a,
I actually saw a documentary on this,
on why the melons in
Japan are so expensive.
- [Connor] They do this
with everything though.
- Yeah, they do, it's a
very Japanese culture thing
where it's just like, they only
pick the cream of the crop.
Every melon is graded and it's perfect.
It's not just the taste.
- [Joey] It's the look.
- It's the look, it's the
crinkling on the side as well.
That gets grade as well
for look and aesthetic.
And I'm just like, "I do not give a shit."
I'm just like, "Is it just kind of sweet?"
Okay, that's cool.
- It's because in Japan,
giving fruit is the utmost-
- It's a flex, right?
- Yeah, it's a flex for
gift giving culture.
- That's like lobsters, they
used to be slavery food, right?
Peasant food?
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, it
used to be peasant food.
- Now they're a delicacy.
- I don't know if fruit is the same way.
(all laugh)
But yeah, 'cause in Japan
gift giving such a huge thing
and giving fruit to
someone is like, "Oh, shit,
you really care for me."
- Yeah.
- [Joey] So that's why
they make it expensive.
- It won't work on us, right?
- It won't work on us
'cause we're just like,
"Just give me a fucking
granny Smith and I'm good."
- Yeah, just go to the
grocery store and buy me
a cheaper grape.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I'm like, "You spent how
much on this watermelon?"
- Yeah.
'Cause I've noticed that
about, I guess the Japanese
artisan culture, which I
guess I'm gonna call it,
which is like, one thing
I can say about Japan
is that if you're a craftsman,
you put your fucking heart and soul
into whatever you're making, right?
I mean, that's why Japan
has such a high standards
for so many things, right?
And you know, you see this
with, for example, you know,
like Japanese tools, like
Japanese knives for example.
You see documentaries about, you know,
people who have inherited
their fucking grand,
great, great grandfather's
fucking blacksmith or so it.
- Fourth generation success.
- Every single one of those
documentaries is the same.
- Yeah.
- They're all the same.
- And then they'll be like,
"Oh, what makes your salt
so special?" And then they'll
go on about the family recipe
and how they love it and love salt.
- It almost always starts with,
"This isn't just any knife."
(Garnt laughing)
- I picked it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Climbed from the Rocky mountains.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Of the Northern Hemisphere.
- This has been passed
down through the knowledge
of fucking five different generations.
- [Joey] My great, great,
great, great grandfather
first made knives.
- And then it's the same way
with the melons, for example,
where you look at the
melon farms and it's like-
- They literally massage it.
- Yeah, they literally massage it.
- Every morning there's just
a dude who's just like this.
- I thought you were joking about that.
- No, no, no, they actually do that.
It's like they're rubbing a baby's head.
- I don't know why.
- You know, I respect the
fact that they have such pride
with their work and their craft,
but there's a point when
I'm just gonna be like,
"It's just a melon" You know? (laughs)
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
- It's really cool and I have
so much respect for people
who do that kind of stuff,
but I'm not always gonna
buy into it.
- Yeah, yeah.
There are some things where
I'm just like, you know,
there are some tools where I'm just like,
"Yes, this definitely does
need the care and attention
and the knowledge of years of work."
And then sometimes I'm
just like, "Ah, I mean,
it's slightly sweeter, you know?
It's a slightly sweet strawberry.
Is it worth that much?
I don't know, I don't know."
- It just doesn't work in other countries.
- It doesn't, it doesn't.
- It reminds me of
Meilyne when she's like,
"These eggs are $8.
$8 eggs."
(all laughing)
- Meilyne is the person that buys into it.
- She made Emily buy it and
she's like, Emily got ready,
and she's like, "I'm
gonna try it, Meilyne says
it's $8 eggs and it
tastes rich and stuff."
- I taste it, I'm like,
"Tastes like an egg with rice."
(all laugh)
- [Meilyne] Daidus has no taste!
- No, I am exactly the same.
- I'm team Daidus here.
- I'm team Daidus here, yeah.
- It's a load of shit.
- It is.
- I'm sorry, if the melon's
fucking ready to eat,
I don't need Tanaka San to massage it.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I'll just eat it.
- I'll do it myself.
- I'll eat it.
I don't know, to me, it's just like,
I don't know, this obsessive nature of
the fruit and things have to be perfect.
And it's like, in the UK as
well, we used to, I think,
throw away carrots or stuff
that weren't the right shape.
- Right.
- People wouldn't buy them,
and it's like, "Just
fucking give it to me."
- I wouldn't mind so much
if there at least was
a cheaper option, you know?
- [Connor] Right, right.
- You know, because it feels
like, you know, I'm fine,
if I wanna, you know, treat
myself, and I know I'm going to
buy a fruit that is 100% of
the time fucking A grade,
you know?
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You know sometimes you
buy a pack of strawberries
in the UK, and it's like strawberry gacha.
Sometimes it's a little bit
sour, sometimes you get that
perfectly sweet one, but you
know, it's like, in Japan,
every strawberry you buy
is like that sweet one.
Every single time.
But I do want the option to just be like,
"Yeah, just give me a fucking cheap pack.
Give me the shit pack that
I just wanna stuff myself."
- It's literally like pay to win.
- It is!
Oh my fucking God.
- It's like, you are paying
so that you guarantee every
strawberry is gonna be an SSR.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah!
Oh my fucking God.
- It's just like, why did they
put fruit behind a pay wall?
All the foods to put behind a paywall.
- The other thing I wouldn't
mind either is, you know,
say for example, if it's knives, right?
Or tools or something.
- That makes sense.
- That shit's gonna last
you for a long time, right?
Because there's quality to it.
I can finish a packet of
strawberries in five minutes,
you know?
So it's like, "Oh, cool,
so the thing I just spent
five minutes on, that cost $200."
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I want a parody documentary
of flaming hot Cheeto,
a premium version being made.
- "This isn't just any flavor."
- They hand-dust it or something.
They spread the dust on.
- This is made by Chester Cheetah himself.
(all laugh)
- They hand-fry every single
Cheeto before dusting it
with fucking-
- Then massage it to the perfect shape.
- It's infused with fairy
dust or some shit like that.
But yeah, I suppose,
unlike us, you moved here
post COVID, right?
So I'm curious what the
procedure for you was like.
- Oh yeah, I forgot, we talked about that.
- Yeah, we went on a tangent.
We do that a lot here
on Trash Taste, yeah.
- Okay.
- Yeah, so take us through,
take us through the process.
- Oh, yeah, it was a, first.
Oh, voice crack. (laughs)
Anyways.
- Why you pointed at me?
- Because you told me
it was a painful process
and I was like, "Hey,
it can't be that bad."
And then, you know, it's
fine, we're just chilling,
waiting for the border to open,
but then when it actually
opened, it was such a pain.
You sign one paper with
the same information.
And then you have to
do that 20 more times.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then you have to, I
had to drive to the bureau,
which is only in Boston.
Drive all the way there.
- Oh, the embassy?
- The embassy.
And then the lady was like,
"Who's this Gaijin trying to get
into our country?"
She treated me like trash.
I was like, "Yeah, fair
enough, I understand."
(all laugh)
- And then she's like, "Come back a week."
Drive back and then drive it again.
Get that thing.
- It's very frustrating
having to go to the embassies.
Especially if they're far away.
- Yeah, when they're far away,
and you don't know how they operate.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then that whole
ordeal happened, and then,
luckily I had the passport ready.
But then the annoying part was the COVID,
they call it My SOS.
It's an app.
- It's the app to get in to Japan.
- Oh, yeah, right.
- What's super troll about this is that
when I got to the airport,
when I landed in Japan,
the app stopped working,
and then all these people
who couldn't communicate
with me were like,
"Why is your phone not working?"
And I was like, "It's not just me.
All these other people's
apps aren't working."
- The app is really
buggy, it's really shit.
- So then they sent me to
a computer to put the same
information I did 37 times.
So I had to do it again.
And then, yeah.
- Yeah, so to explain, this is the app.
I just have it as well 'cause
I just came into Japan.
- Do they call you?
- They don't call me 'cause
I don't need to quarantine
'cause I'm boosted.
- They called me.
You're boosted? (chuckles)
- I'm boosted!
- I'm boosted, baby!
- Yeah, they called me.
They checked on me every
day when I came back.
- [Daidus] Really?
- Yeah, they called me on stream
and I did it on the stream.
- Yeah, yeah.
Last time when we needed to quarantine,
they call you every day, but
I believe now you just have to
download it just to register
that you are coming into
the country.
- If it works.
I mean, I felt like, I got like,
because I'd done this
before and I did it through
hard mode, right?
When I came in, we were
literally treated like cattle.
We'd come in and they'd
tag us and brand us
and be like-
- Really?
- Yeah.
"Those are the people coming in."
We literally spent four
hours in the airport.
How long did you spend in the airport?
- Very quick.
Well, not quick quick,
because you know, the whole.
Maybe three hours.
Three hours.
- That's pretty good considering
you were getting the visa.
- Yeah.
Yeah, and you were
getting the visa as well.
- Can I talk shit about Delta?
- Yeah, you can talk shit about anything.
- We're not sponsored by them.
- Bro, that's literally our partner.
(all laugh)
- I own the shares to Delta, actually.
- Yo, fuck Delta, dude.
I've rode with them three times,
they fucked me over all three times.
But anyways, they delayed my fucking...
- Flight.
- My flight by a day.
And what the thing is that
you needed the COVID test
three days.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But you get results in two days.
- Yeah.
- So I had to time it perfectly.
And then when I did time it perfectly,
Delta canceled my Japan trip.
They made me get stuck in Detroit.
I'm literally just stuck
in Detroit all night.
And then when I got to the
airport, they were like,
"Hey, your COVID test is late by a day."
And then I had to show my ticket, like,
"Yo, they delayed me by whole day."
Then they had to bring the
manager and then the manager
had to bring the other manager,
and then the manager managers
had to bring the other manager
and he came over and he was
like, "Okay, you're good."
(all laugh)
- That's the most Japanese story
I've ever heard in my life.
- And I'm like, "Just get me in
the god damn country already."
I'm tired, I'm sweaty.
- Yeah.
- See, I think,
I think I must have taken
the most optimized path
you could possibly get
to take in the country,
'cause I was only at the
airport for an hour and a half,
but I prepared my COVID tests,
I made sure it was dated
and timed and made sure to
print out all my tickets.
- I did that too.
- Yeah?
- I had a folder.
- Did you pre-register as well?
- I did.
- You did?
- I did, and it didn't work.
It wouldn't work.
And I even screen shotted the barcode.
- Oh, yeah?
- But they didn't take it.
- Was the app green?
- No, because only one
of them wasn't accepting
my vaccine card for some
reason, and I was like, "Why?"
- So you need to make sure
you get the right kind
of vaccine card, and then
if you get the right kind
of vaccine card, the app will turn green,
and if they see a green
app, they're just like,
"Let this man through,
let this man through."
- "He's got a green card, baby!"
- "He's not like the rest."
- "He's done the paperwork.
He's done the paperwork,
get him through." (laughs)
Yeah, literally, I think I
skipped an hour and a half
to two hours just because I
was able to get the green app.
- Good to know.
I need to do that.
- Well, thanks for telling me.
- Yeah, I need to know that.
- I've done the speed run,
guys, I've done the speed run.
- I've optimized the run.
- I've optimized it.
Yeah, 'Cause I knew how anal
Japan were with documents,
so I was just like, "I need
to make sure every document
is on par with their
exact specifications."
- When you do something in
the UK, and I assume the US,
sometimes you read some stuff,
guidelines, you're like,
"Oh, I'm sure that's not
that important" Right?
In Japan, if it's written
there, they are gonna check.
- [Garnt] Yeah, they
will check everything.
- They will make sure.
- Japan is the only country
where you actually have to read
the fine print, 'cause they do everything
the fine print says.
- I did, I want above and
beyond, and I still got
kind of cut by it.
- That's Japan for you.
- That is Japan.
- [Joey] That's Japan for you.
- So yeah, you still took
three hours just because
you had to re-sign everything?
- Oh, actually, well, the day before that,
when I transferred it to Detroit.
- Yeah.
- They kept being like,
"Oh, we're gonna get another pilot."
One hour later, "Oh, the pilot's coming."
One hour later, three hours
later, and then they go,
"Oh, canceled."
And then like, "Here's your hotel."
Go to a hotel, waste a whole ass day.
Go the next day, and then,
you know, finally load.
Then I got out of the airport, three hours
and then Meilyne picked
me up and I was like.
And then I met you guys at the, that...
- That restaurant?
- That restaurant
that was pretty mid.
(Joey laughs)
- This episode sponsored by Honey,
the easy way to save when
shopping on your iPhone
or computer.
- Guys, you know we all shop online.
Of course we do.
Where else do we shop, in real life?
Now, how often do you
feel that that promo code
just taunts you at the checkout?
- Every time.
- Well, thanks to Honey, manually
searching for coupon codes
are a thing of the past.
- [Joey] Really?
- Honey's the free
shopping tool that scours
the internet for promo codes
and applies the best one
it finds to your cart.
- Woo.
- [Connor] Imagine it, you're
shopping on one of your
favorite sites.
As you get to the checkout,
the Honey button appears
and all you have to do
is click, "Apply coupon."
Wait a few seconds as honey
searches through coupons
it can find for that site.
If Honey finds a working coupon,
you'll watch the prices drop.
- Oh my Lord.
- I recently bought some
nice dress shirts, gentlemen.
I know, I know, fancy,
'cause we're going to the UK,
and I managed to save 15
bucks on a $100 order,
thanks to Honey.
- [Joey] Damn.
- 15 bucks?
- I know, I know.
- Ladies and gentlemen, if you
haven't already used Honey,
you could be straight up
missing out on savings,
and by getting it, you'll
be doing yourself a solid
and supporting the boys as well.
So, you can get Honey for free
at joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
That's joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
Back to the episode.
- I gotta say, since
Daidus and Emily came like,
after GeeXPlus has already
obviously been formed
for a while.
They got the fucking VIP
treatment coming into Japan.
They got picked up at
the airport by Meilyne
and GeeXPlus staff, you know.
I believe Emily got the same
treatment, where me and Connor,
we were just left to find
our way to our house.
- Find Joey.
- Yeah, Find Joey basically.
- I had to pick them up.
I'm there like, "Guys."
- I texted Joey when I landed
in Japan and I was like,
"Hey, can you come help me?
I've got so many bags."
And then he helped me out
in like (speaks Japanese).
- Yeah, and-
- Joey was the one who took care of me.
- And I remember that because
I remember trying to do
the same thing to Connor,
'cause me and Sydney
were going to stay around
Connor's house, right?
And Connor was just like,
"Yeah, Joey helped me
with his bags and everything like that."
Have I told it on the podcast?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Okay.
- About me not helping you, Garnt.
I didn't know you had that many bags.
I would've helped if I'd known, all right?
- The most fucked up thing,
I hadn't even joined GeeXPlus
at that time.
I was literally just doing
it on my own volition.
Meanwhile Meilyne's just fuck sitting back
eating her $8 eggs.
(all laugh)
Like, "Yeah, you'll be all right."
- [Meilyne] They were under 8.
Not that I care.
- Yeah, back then
GeeXPlus was just Meilyne
and now GeeXPlus is an
entire team, so of course-
- I'm surprised.
- Yeah, they put him up in a hotel.
- Yeah.
- We were the beta test basically.
- We stayed in hotel Joey. (chuckles)
- I stayed in hotel Connor.
Slept on his floor, you know,
that was very luxurious.
- Tatami mat actually.
- Tatami mat, okay, I'm sorry.
- Come on, it's authentic.
- Technically it is a floor.
- It's authentic, it's not a floor.
- It's four generations old, actually.
Handcrafted and massaged.
- It's not of just a floor.
Jesus Christ.
It's thousands of years of
culture you're sleeping on.
Jesus.
- So once you got into the
country, everything was good,
you reckon?
- Well...
(everyone chuckles)
I mean, we always needed a translator.
We translated everything, literally.
- Yeah, that was Joey's
job at the beginning.
Wasn't even paid for it.
- I wasn't even paid for it.
- We're lucky because you
guys are already established,
so you guys go, "Oh, you
wanna go out to here?"
And I'm like, "Okay" And
then you do all the speaking
and I'm just like.
- [Joey] Just sitting there.
- Yeah, and then, well,
we did our first lesson
two weeks ago, but then golden
week hit, so we just like.
- Oh, you're going to Japanese lessons?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh, nice.
- For sure, for sure.
I feel so useless, man.
I really do.
- It does make you feel like an infant.
You just can't do anything.
- Yeah, I just, I feel so,
I never felt so useless
in my life, but that's
what I like about it.
- You like that?
- [Daidus] No, no.
- The challenge?
Okay, okay.
"I don't wanna do anything.
Let everyone else do everything for me."
- No, no, no, no, no.
- That's cool though, because
I don't know many people
who have never left their
country who are suddenly
just like, "Yeah, you know what?
I'm just gonna live in a country
I've never been to" You know?
- Yeah.
- If you live in your mom's
basement long enough, you just...
- [Joey] You want to?
- I've been there for a very long time.
- Right, right, right.
- I mean, but rent is
insane in the US, right?
Getting a place to rent.
- It was my mom's basement.
- If you wanted to leave
your mom's basement,
the rent is really high.
- It depends on what state you're in.
- It depends where you are, I guess.
I don't know what it's like in Maine,
but I guess New York.
- Maine's getting cheaper,
no, more expensive
'cause the hipsters are moving in.
- [Joey] Right, right.
- It's kind of like Williamsburg.
They made it super expensive.
- Well, I mean, I know New
York is fucking egregious.
- Brooklyn, actually,
when I went to Brooklyn,
it used to be cheap and ghetto,
and then I came back, you know,
a couple years after college
and it completely-
- And now it's super fancy, right?
- It turned fancy, I was like,
"Where's my ghetto Brooklyn
that I miss?"
I missed the ghettoness, where is it?
- Yeah, I've heard it's
become the art district
of New York, right?
A lot of hipsters living in Brooklyn now.
- I literally think it's the
art college is around there.
- You told me that you used
to, you tried to pay rent once
within your sock or something.
- [Joey] What?
- Oh!
Oh, yeah, I was just,
okay, I'll tell this story.
- I was just thinking, you said ghetto.
- It's 2:00 AM in the morning.
- Yeah.
- And I'm like,
"Well, I gotta pay rent to
my roommate real quick."
So I had to, the only way
to do it to was to cash ATM.
- It was in New York, right?
- Yeah, it was in New York.
My Brooklyn apartment.
- Right, right, right.
- And the deli's only five minute walk.
So I'm like, "Okay, I'll just
go to the deli, get the $500."
But I'm so stupid, 'cause
in my head I'm like,
"Well, it's 2:00 AM in the morning,
and what if I get mugged?"
I should hide it in a really good spot,
and I hid it in my shoe.
I hid it in my shoe, and
while I was walking back,
the money flew out of my shoe.
Then I didn't know, and I
got back to my apartment
and I was like, "Where's my money?"
So then I went outside in
the dark, looking like this.
And then a bunch of, you
know, people came up to me
and was like, "Yo, what you looking for?"
And I'm like, "Have you
guys seen any money,
like $500 around?"
And they're like, "Nah, man, nah."
And I knew they were acting.
I think they picked it up.
"Nah, man, nah, dude, I didn't see that.
That's crazy, what?"
And I was like, "Okay, I
know you guys have it."
I didn't say it out loud,
but I'm like, "This is a GG.
I'm gonna call my dad and be like,
"Yeah, I lost the $500, sorry."
(all laugh)
And I felt bad.
- How the fuck did it
fly out of your shoe?
You didn't put it deep into your sole?
- Were you letting it
hang out of the shoe?
- No, I put it as deep as, I don't know.
- Do you have a hole in your shoe, maybe?
It just kinda slipped out.
- No, I just, maybe physics or
something, I don't know, man.
- Physics.
- Physics, man.
Physics.
- I don't know, man.
- Or the mugging was just that good.
- Dude, I mugged myself technically.
(all laugh)
- That is the most, "I
live in New York" Story
I've ever heard.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- Well, my favorite time
in New York is going out
at like, 2:00 AM in the
morning, 'cause then you get
the crack heads.
(men chuckling)
- Why is that a good thing?
- I don't know, it's just
kind of, it's a vibe. (laughs)
(Garnt laughs)
But it's because I'm a dude,
so I'm technically always safe.
But if you're a girl, it's real bad.
- I don't know, man.
I've been to New York
and I never felt safe.
Even during the day.
- Yeah, yeah, no.
Actually, being in Japan,
I always feel safe now.
- [Joey] Yeah, right?
- This is crazy, no
guns, no stabbing, what?
- I don't know if I'd call
that a vibe, you know? (laughs)
- What, lo-fi gun noise?
- No, you just gotta
learn how to talk to them.
So what I do is-
- Wait, you go up and talk to them?
- No, no, if they approach you.
- [Joey] Oh, right.
- Okay, okay.
- So what you do is you gotta
be like a homie to them.
So what I do is I like to
say, "Man" So I'm like,
so they go-
- This is one simple trick
stops all crackheads.
- This is a pro strategy, okay?
So they approach you,
they're like, "Give me $2.
Hey, can I have $2?"
And you go, "No, sorry, man."
And then you gotta add
the, "Man" In there.
It's a heart to heart.
- So if I just say "No, sorry."
They're gonna be like-
- If you just say, "No,
sorry" They're offended.
- I'm not, you know, native to America,
but I don't think that's
gonna stop anything
if someone wants to-
- No, it does, you'd be surprised, man.
(all laugh)
- I was just gonna punch you.
- [Daidus] Yeah, yeah.
- But I just suddenly
felt some connection.
- He's like, "Oh, he's on my level.
Thank God."
- "Oh, he called me man?
Okay, you're good.
You're good, I'll mug the next guy."
(all laugh)
- I'll mug the next.
- What do you think then,
what does the, "Man" Do?
- What does the man do?
- What dude, the dude asking?
- So like-
- No, no, by saying,
"Man" What does that do?
Why does that work?
- Oh, it's just like-
- [Connor] Disarms them?
- Yeah, it's word disarming.
- Right, right.
- I don't know if this is how
it, if this is how it works.
- You're being being
friendly towards them, right?
- Yeah, friendly.
So if you just say, "No, sorry."
That's kind of rude.
You say, "No, sorry, man."
Or in that tone, "No, sorry, man."
Right?
- What if I say,
"Apologies, my good fellow,
I cannot provide you with
the cash that you require
right now."
- Well then you make them laugh.
- "I would like to decline
that request, sir."
(Garnt laughing)
- That's another thing, if
you can make them laugh,
they let you go too, you know?
- I mean, look, I believe you-
- Criminals hate this one simple trick.
- There's part of me that believes you,
but I'm not insane in that I'm
not gonna try it. (chuckles)
- I mean, I haven't been mugged yet, so.
- [Joey] Yeah, well.
- Well, I don't think I'll
be mugged here, right?
- You've got to be pretty unlucky to.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Unless it's an umbrella, in which case,
that's just free reign.
- Oh yeah, someone stole Emily's umbrella.
- Yeah, it do be like that, yeah.
- People don't steal here
unless it's umbrellas.
- Because it's not your umbrella.
It's the community umbrella.
- You gotta be more careful
about people trying to make you
join cults, really.
That's what happens more.
- It hasn't happened to me yet.
- That's good.
It will.
It will happen.
- Do I have to go to the countryside?
- No, don't follow them.
Why are you following them?
- No, you just have to
be like, "Sorry, man."
- "Sorry, man, I'm sorry."
- "Sorry, man, I don't
wanna join your cult.
Sorry, dude."
- And they're like, "You're good, man."
- "I don't want to go and pray."
- "You're good, dude."
- I don't think it'll work
here, they don't understand
English that much.
- The cults do.
- Oh, they do?
- They go for foreigners.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh, then my tactic works.
- Yeah, yeah, just be like, "Sorry, man."
- Just say, "Man" Right?
- "Sorry, man, I don't
wanna join a cult, man."
wanna pray right now."
They'll ask you, "Do you want to pray?"
And you say no, and then
they'll show you a picture
of Mount Fuji, and that
should be your sign.
- Yeah, it's always Mount Fuji.
- I always question, what
exactly do you do in this cult?
They just get money from you?
- Yeah, normally they make
you kind of live with them
and then they try and get your money.
- I mean, it's usually like,
it starts off with a scam.
- It's just brainwashing.
- Yeah, it starts off with a scam
which then eventually
leads on to some more,
I don't wanna say devious
licks, but. (laughs)
- Devious licks. (laughs)
- It gets a little, you know, serious.
- There's that episode
of Golden Town, right?
Where there's a cult thing going on?
- Is there?
- Yeah.
- You know, Japan weirdly
has a lot of cults.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They're really, really, really active.
It's a lot of really big ones as well.
- It's because there's
no one organized religion
like a lot of countries,
so it's kind of just
free for all, basically.
- I'm guessing 'cause of the
aging population as well.
It's very easy to-
- I can't unsee it.
I was fine, and then
Connor, randomly while I was
hanging out with him.
This dude just randomly dropped,
"Yeah, there's like a lot
of old people, more old
people than young people."
And I was like, "No, there's not."
Then the next week I've been
walking around, I'm like,
"My God, they're everywhere!"
(everyone laughs)
There's old people everywhere.
- If you go to a supermarket,
it's probably like,
80% elderly people.
- It's insane.
I was like, "Whoa."
- I was just like, I saw a news
article just the other day.
I mean, this is outdated by
the time being, but like,
do you know what percentage
of the population is below 15
in Japan?
- Wait, what did you say?
Repeat that again.
- What percentage of
the Japanese population
is below 15 years old?
What do you think?
- 20%.
- [Joey] 10%.
- What the fuck?
- That's how many old people there are,
or older people there are.
- [Garnt] Less young people there are.
- This is what happens
when everyone plays Gacha.
No one's having sex.
- I agree with that.
(all laugh)
I went to Akihabara and the sex
shop is all I needed to see.
(all laugh)
- Oh, you went to it?
- I did, and I saw some questionable.
- [Joey] The four story one, right?
- Yeah.
The advertisement there was just like.
I would pretend not to look.
- So, how does New York as
a big city compare to Tokyo?
Living there.
- Tokyo is amazing.
I actually, I love it here.
It's literally New York, but clean.
(all laugh)
- Ladies and Gentlemen, you're welcome.
- As well, New York has the
grid system, which is like,
it gets boring, because you
just walk straight lines, right?
- Yeah.
- Japan has just, you get
straight lines and then.
- Yeah, like lots of little like.
- That's it, that's all you know?
No food differences, no
restaurant differences?
- Oh my God, dude.
(laughing)
- You're looking at it in
the eyes of an architect.
- I'm like, "Straight lines.
Japan, everyone." (vocalizes swishing)
- I lost like, 20 pounds
before getting here.
Obviously not at my goal.
- Right.
- Which I hate.
But anyways, I'm trying to
fucking lose weight here
in Japan.
Impossible.
You go down one street,
food, food, food, food.
Go to the next one,
Food, food, food.
Snack, snack, snack, snack.
It's impossible.
And it's all carbs.
I can't control myself, I'm like.
- [Connor] And then you have a beer.
- What?
- And then you have a beer.
- And then you have a
beer, which is cheap,
because if you wanna buy a beer,
normally if you go to the bar,
you have to tip the bartender.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then the beer costs
$8 so it's $9 a beer.
Over here is what, like three bucks?
- Yeah.
- No tip.
- [Joey] If that.
- I've been to some izakayas
where it's 50 yen a beer.
- Oh, okay, wow.
Really cheap beers.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that's what I noticed.
They have low carb beer too.
- The green label, right?
- I showed him the green stuff.
- Why would you do that?
Why would you do that?
- It's good!
- Because he was constantly
complaining about carbs
and stuff, and I was like-
- Just don't drink beer.
- I was like, "Daidus has shit taste.
He'll probably like this beer."
And I gave it to him, he was like,
"This tastes pretty good."
- Why drink beer then?
(Garnt laughing)
- It's just fun, I don't know.
- Just get a high ball.
- It's literally like water.
It doesn't taste like beer.
- Yeah, I like water.
- I'm not dissing water here.
I'm not a water hater.
- The audacity.
- It's like Bud light.
Super light.
- It is literally Bud light.
Do you like Bud light?
- It's water.
- A can is like, a hundred
calories and like, no carbs,
so it's pretty, you know,
if you're on a diet,
it's pretty friendly.
- Well, the thing in America right now.
In America right now
what's very popular is
the hard seltzer.
- What's that?
- You don't know that?
- Seltzer water.
- It's literally seltzer water
but they put alcohol in it.
- What's seltzer water?
- Isn't it carbonated water?
- It's carbonated water.
- Oh, so it's like White Claw?
Is that it?
- I guess, supposedly.
- White Claw?
Well, White Claw puts a
little bit of flavoring in it.
- Okay.
So they've removed the fun.
- It is White Claw.
Isn't basically a White Claw.
- They've removed the fun from White Claw,
which already wasn't fun originally.
- It depends on which seltzer you want.
But yeah, White Claw is
the most popular one.
- Okay, okay, okay.
- But they put alcohol in it?
- They do.
Like five to six, eight
per cent or something.
- Oh, so it's like a Strong Zero.
- No, a Strong Zero is sugary.
- It's basically just, yeah, alcohol water
or something, right?
- It's hand sanitizer.
- What length have we gone
to when this is the norm?
- Seltzer water is just
water but carbonated.
You never had seltzer water?
- What's difference
between sparkling then?
- Sparkling, normally
they call sparkling when
it has flavor-enhanced.
- Really?
- Does it?
- I don't think they do, no.
- Like Aspartame or whatever
it's called, Aspartame?
- What's the other one?
There's a bunch of other brands.
What is it, Perrier or whatever?
- Perrier?
That's sparkling water, right?
- It's got no flavor.
- That's just sparkling water though.
- It doesn't have flavor in it though?
- But that that's what sparkling water is.
- What's the difference between seltzer?
- Oh, seltzer, sorry.
Seltzer water.
- But it says sparkling.
- I'm talking out of on my own ass.
I don't fucking know.
Maybe they're the same thing.
- Welcome to Trash Taste.
- Tell me what your source is.
- I made it up, fuck off.
- I feel like seltzer
water is unflavored though,
and then sparkling's like,
"Here's a cherry flavor."
- Yeah, yeah, I guess.
- So did you find that Japan
is giving you any inspiration?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Super motivation.
- [Connor] Really?
- Yeah 'cause when I made,
you know, when I did YouTube
as a job back in United
States or Maine or whatever,
in my mom's basement basically.
- Yeah.
- I didn't really have
any reason to make money.
When I did make money,
I was like, "All right."
But I never had a use for it,
'cause I didn't pay for
my food, my mom, you know.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But then my mom was like,
"You should move out."
But she's also very sad about it too.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I'm like, "Oh, man, I'm conflicted."
But then I'm like, "I gotta move out.
I have to, mentally."
I was rotting down there.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Especially when, I
think I wanted to move out
before COVID hit and then
COVID hit and I was like,
"Well, I'll just be a
basement dweller again."
- Right, right, right.
- Eat dominoes pizza.
- Did you always plan to move
to Japan or was it just like,
the opportunity came and you're like,
"All right, this is it, this
is what I've been waiting for.
I'll take anything."
- I mean, if the opportunity
arise, I was just,
"Okay, yeah."
- I mean, you got an
opportunity that a lot of people
would kill for.
- Yeah.
I mean, I'm a weeb, right?
- We know.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's just really weird
going to the konbini
and seeing detective Conan and I'm like...
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Or we'll go on the train and
I'll see Gacha advertisements
or nice anime art, and
I'm like, "This is crazy."
I was like, "This is pretty wild."
- I'm so sad 'cause I missed out on the,
'cause I wasn't in Tokyo
when you were here.
- Yeah, we gotta hang out, by the way.
- Yeah, of course, but I
missed out on the initial
Daidus reacts to Japan saga that happened.
- Well, I'm still like, every
time I go to a Konbini store,
I'm still like, "What
is this, what is that?"
There's so many things, you know?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I love seeing reactions
to people who come to Japan
for the first time.
They're just like, "Woo!"
To everything, right?
- 'Cause I remember my first reaction
seeing a fucking konbini and just like.
- Yeah, the konbini is the funnest one.
- It is, it.
- "I've gone to the konbini,
I've seen Japan now, I'm done."
- Like, "Fuck Akihabara, it's
all about the konbinis, man."
- Knobini's peak Japan.
- What's your go to food
then at the konbini?
What are you eating?
- I like 7-eleven the best.
- Yeah, what are you eating though?
- Oh, I'm not-
- Everything or?
- No, not everything, just whatever.
I'm trying to stay healthy, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Have you had the cup ramen yet?
- No.
- It's pretty good.
You should try it.
- Did you not hear what he just said?
He's trying to lose weight.
- Try it.
Curry flavor.
- Just a little.
- Curry flavor.
- I notice they only have
the tin cans or whatever.
Not the tin cans, the plastic cups, right?
- [Joey] The plastic cups?
- In America they got the little bags.
- Oh, like the packet ramen?
- Yeah.
- No, no, they have
packet ramen here as well.
- It's just everyone likes the cup one.
- I can't find the cups ever.
- Wait, what?
- Wait, what do you mean?
The cups are everywhere.
- Cups are everywhere.
- Oh, sorry, I meant.
- Oh, the package?
- The package.
- No, the package shit
you probably need to go to
a super market for.
- Yeah, they sell them
at the super market.
- Why would you want the packet shit?
- So you can eat it at home.
- It tastes better.
- No.
- You get to deck it yourself.
- Oh, what the fuck?
No, dude.
- Why not just make a cup ramen
and then just empty it out
into a plate?
Would that not be the same thing?
- I fucking love the
curry cup ramen, dude.
- The curry one or the tomato
one are my favorites, yeah.
- I fucking love the big curry one.
- I think they all taste the same.
Right?
- What?
- Right?
- Oh, it's just another, "All
bread tastes the same" Thing.
- No, no.
- The flavors taste very different, Garnt.
- There's a Curry one that's really good,
and then there's a tomato
one that's really good.
There's a seafood one that's really good.
- Well, I worry for your taste buds.
- No, no, I'm saying if
there's cup ramen in a cup,
and ramen in a packet
that's the same flavor,
they both taste the same.
- Oh, I thought you were saying the Curry
and the tomato ones taste the same.
- Oh, right, no, I was just,
'cause he was talking about
the packet, because they taste better.
- They taste the same.
- Yeah, they taste the same.
- No, it depends on what sauce you get.
- The one with the cup
they've given you literally
the perfect measurement
of water to put in.
In a bowl, I always over do
it or under do it, you know?
- Well you gotta get good, bro.
- That just means you
haven't cooked enough ramen
out of a bowl.
- I like pot noodles, I like
the cup noodles way more,
and also, dude, there's something so fun
about holding it.
- You're just lazier.
You don't wanna boil the water.
You just wanna like.
- Half of the experience
is just fucking holding it
and just fucking going at it.
- No, but it's hot, it burns your hand.
- What? (laughs)
- Put it in a bowl.
- Are you holding it while
you're pouring the hot water in?
- Dude, sometimes the heat
goes through the styrofoam
and you're like, "Ah."
(Joey laughs)
- What are you, what?
- Am I the only one?
- Please, Joey, mate.
- I mean, I've never had that.
I don't know how sensitive the
nerves on your fingers are.
(Connor gasps)
- I don't know, because with
some, depending on the packet
of flavor of the ramen, I
think it requires a different
amount of water for the
optimal taste, in my opinion.
You know, some sauces are a bit thicker.
Some sauces are a bit thicker.
You like yours watery?
Nah, I like it thick, man.
I like it concentrated.
- I like it watery.
(Garnt laughing)
- So, but that's the thing,
the cup ramen, right?
They have a line on the
inside, which is like,
"This is the normal one."
So if you like yours watery,
you just pour a little more
water than the line.
If you like it thick, you
pour a little bit under.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- It's perfectly measured out for you.
So there's no, you know,
gambling in a fucking giant pot.
- You guys sound like a cup ramen cult.
- I just like cup ramen.
- I like cup ramen!
- Cup ramen is fucking awesome.
- It's good.
- I mean, I ain't trashing it, it's good.
I just prefer the packets more.
- It was invented by Americans, dude.
- You sound like you're
talking a little too much shit.
- [Daidus] The cup?
- Yeah.
- Oh, cool.
- It actually was, actually.
- It was invented by the Americans.
- Learned that at the
cup noodle museum, right?
Yeah, the cup ramen museum.
- Ah.
- I'll take you to the cup ramen museum
and then you'll change your mind.
- Think someone went there before.
- I think people have gone there before.
- We've all been there.
- Oh, okay.
(men laugh)
- "I think I know someone".
- People have gone there.
- People have gone there before, I think.
I think two of them are
in this room right now.
- I think Emily went to it, I think.
- [Joey] Oh, really?
- I think there's one in
California, that's why.
- Oh.
- Oh, really?
I didn't know that.
- So I guess we should talk
a bit more about what you do.
- Yeah.
- Oh, yeah.
- Well, I met you guys at a Fakku party.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, at anime expo, right?
- What year was that?
- Well, it was whenever the lost one was.
- 2019.
- But wait, wait, actually,
what's your YouTube history?
Why the fuck are you on YouTube?
What's going on with that, huh?
- Oh.
Why am I on YouTube?
- Yeah, what brought you on YouTube?
- Oh yeah, okay, okay.
I get it here.
(all laughing)
I graduated college
and I didn't want to be
a industry puppet yet.
- Yeah, what did you study in college?
- I went for 3D animation, which I hate.
- Okay.
- I hate 3D animation.
- 3D animation?
- I went 3D animation because
obviously career-wise,
it's safest.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- If you go to art college,
you're paying like,
50 grand, whatever, every
semester and you know,
getting massively in debt.
- 50 grand every semester?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, art college.
- Art college don't mess around, dude.
And then they make you pay for the dorms,
and then they make you pay for everything.
And then they give you this
lunch card and they're like,
"We put $15,000 in here.
You have to spend it all or it goes away."
So you have to keep
eating at the cafeteria
to spend all that money.
- [Joey] Right, right, right.
- Or else the money's useless.
It's so stupid.
But anyways.
Yeah, so, after I graduated,
I was jobless for like,
a year and a half, two years.
I don't know how long.
It was probably the most
depressing parts of my life.
It was very depressing because at first,
because I wanted to try
to do something myself,
instead of being a paint bucket slave.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Paint, bucket, paint bucket.
I was like, "Let me try to do something."
It was a massive struggle.
I'd release a video and
then it would do poorly
because obviously when you're
like one subscriber, indy,
you're like, "I can't do much." Right?
So then it was just that,
I just kept doing it
because I saw people like
Dominic, James, Jayden and stuff.
They were doing well at the
time, Story Time animation
was very-
- Oh, that was crazy.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That was the peak of that.
- It is dying now a little bit, obviously.
- You think so?
- I think so, yeah.
- Dying, well, it's not dying dying.
- It's calmed down a lot.
- [Daidus] It's calmed down.
- It's definitely not at the peak, yeah.
- It used to be insane.
You could make any video and
be like, "I went to school
and I sat down and I saw a
pencil and I sharpened it."
And then you could get
a million views on it.
(Joey laughs)
- I remember when it was at
its peak, it was like every,
no matter how many times
you refresh your homepage,
there was a Story Time.
- There was a different Story Time.
- It worked.
- I think James's style was so simple
that everyone was like,
"Oh, I can do that too."
- [Joey] Right, right.
- That's what happened.
- Yeah 'cause I remember before,
some of the biggest YouTube
videos were animation,
and then YouTube changed
the algorithm to watch time.
- People want animation.
- Yeah, but people, the need
never went so, you know,
there was this huge need and
want on the YouTube audience
for animation, but obviously
it wasn't feasible to do
the heavy, New Grounds kind of
short form animation anymore,
and then that kind of evolved
into Story Time animations,
I think.
- It funny though.
It's because it's supposed
to be simpler now,
but now everyone has teams.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I wish I had it too.
I mean, I should try to get one,
but I have that mental
problem where I'm like,
"I must do it."
- Yeah.
- "I must be the one.
You won't do it correctly.
I gotta do it."
And I hate that, I hate that.
- Yeah, that's definitely
something you need to let go of
as a YouTuber.
- It's so hard.
It's the same with you
guys with editing, right?
- I'm the same way and I
still am heavily involved
in the editing process.
- Yeah 'cause you're
like. (breathes rapidly)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
'cause to me, that is my personality.
I can convey my personality
through my editing,
so I've had to learn what parts
can I give to someone else
and not lose this to be like
a gig up video, you know?
That's what I've had to figure out.
And that's what the challenge
is, 'cause you can't continue
doing everything yourself, you
have to figure out, you know,
what makes a Daidus video a Daidus video
and what can I outsource to other people
to help me with, you know?
- Yeah because I'm sure
you could get, you know,
helpers to do say like, coloring
and stuff like that, right?
- That's the hard part though is that
when it comes to animation,
it's expensive because
there's a lot of hours
that get put into it.
And in my head I'm like, "Well,
if I'm doing the writing,
the storyboarding, the
animation, the YouTube thumbnail,
the whatever."
There's so many, I'm doing everything.
- [Joey] Right.
- Yeah.
- And I'm like, "If I give
this to somebody else,
all they're gonna do is
just make it polished
and make it look better, right?
- Yeah, but let's say-
- I don't technically
save time that way though.
- There's some things you can do-
- It just looks better.
- Let's say you're writing, right?
You could argue that you
have to write everything,
but what's wrong with someone
kind of mimicking your style
and then you going in and cleaning it up?
The more you work with someone-
- I would love that, I just need to find-
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's all about finding
that person, yeah.
- It sucks 'cause you need
to find someone, but also.
- And then you have to pay them good.
- You have to train them.
So you don't see a return.
- Train them, pay them.
- But in the long run, you'll
probably save some investment.
- I do want to do that because I get,
I love doing the videos of
course, but it is a lot of work
and I don't like to say out
loud that it's a lot of work
because it's like.
- It's obviously a lot of work.
- No, the problem is that there's artists
who are doing that, but
better or faster than you,
or draw better than you.
You know, I'd say I'm pretty good,
but then pixiv artists are like.
- [Joey] Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Well, take a, what is your
entire process into making
one of your videos?
- Well first-
- From start to end.
- Ah, okay.
Well, first of all, you
gotta think of like,
"Okay, what's a good enough
video that won't be boring?"
I go for the ADHD kind of fast paced.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Yeah, right, right, right, right.
- But the problem is, I
learned that the hard way
that I've been doing this
so much, I run out of jokes
'cause I'm like, "Well, I've
done this, I've done this.
Death note?
I've done that.
Another death note?
I've done that."
(men laugh)
I've put so many death note
references in there already.
I'm like, "Oh, well I need to
change my style or something
'cause I'm running out of jokes, man."
But yeah, so I start with the topic,
you half write it, you bullet point.
- Yeah.
- And you storyboard,
storyboarding is the longest
because that's basically the whole video,
and then you just have
to clean it up, right?
- Right.
- So story, oh yeah, sorry,
you gotta do the audio
because now you gotta match
the audio with the storyboard.
And then, and I hate the audio the most,
I hate audio the most.
- Why'd you hate audio?
- When it's a home setup,
it's like, I don't know,
I have a hard time,
because with animation,
every sentence that you make is at least
like five to ten drawings.
And you're like, "Okay,
I gotta cut this down
so I don't have to
animate an extra 30, 40,
50, 60 drawings.
So you have to cut it perfectly.
- Right.
- To save you some drawing time basically.
And I don't know, I just
feel like the expectations
are really high for any artist on YouTube,
because there's always gonna
be that guy in the comments
that's like, "What, that's it?
That was shit" Or something like that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah but fuck him. (chuckles)
- Yeah, right.
I don't know, there's
always that guy that's like,
"What happened, your quality went down?"
Well, my quality went down
because I have to release
the video for you.
You want it faster, right?
But then you take too long, they go,
"Where's the video?"
And then it kind of
like, it burns you out.
I wouldn't say I'm burnt out.
I would say I would make the video,
then I get burnt out for like a month.
And then I come back,
but at least I enjoy it,
so I'll do it again.
I'll keep doing it.
The problem is, I don't know
if it's Animation or Story Time
or whatever.
They made this thing in
the air, which is like,
oh, you gotta do it monthly, monthly.
I don't know why.
- Like a standard.
- I think that's probably
an expectation of like,
this seems like a
reasonable amount of time
for it to take.
But also, I'd probably
say that's YouTube's,
a good way to remind YouTube
that you still exist.
- [Daidus] Yeah, exactly.
- Please recommend my video.
- So things like when we, me
and Emily do stuff with Connor
on his channel or whatever,
it's like, "Hey, we're still
alive, we're just suffering
from anime injuries.
We've been drawing a lot.
I try not to draw more than
three frames, I'm just like.
- [Joey] yeah.
- Because most of it is
the jokes and the audio.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then the visuals are just bonus.
And some animators, they don't,
they take that too lightly
and the animate too much,
and then they're like,
"Oh, man, why did I do this?" (chuckles)
- Right, right, right.
So how long does it take
to make one of your videos
do you reckon?
- Without rushing it.
- Yeah, without rushing.
- Like, hours.
- Well, the thing is, in
the mental, you need to be,
oh, sorry, sorry.
- Wanna make sure it's
pointed towards your mouth.
- [Joey] Eat the mic.
- Yeah, so...
- You can move it around.
- What was the question?
- How long does it take to
make one of your videos?
If you're not rushing.
- All right, okay.
So the thing is you need
to be in the mental state.
Because I think, you guys are,
I call you guys live actioners.
(Garnt laughs)
- Mate, I'm not a live actioner.
- FleshTuber.
- You're a FleshTuber.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- Whether you like it or not, Garnt,
you are a FleshTuber.
- That sounds like a toy that
Sydney just bought, you know?
- The flesh tube 3,000.
(men laughing)
- But for you guys, you
can set up everything
and then be done within
an hour or two or three.
- Not necessarily.
- Well, it depends, yeah.
- Well, it depends, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Right.
I'm not saying it's easy,
I'm saying it's like-
- It's more streamlined, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- If you're not feeling it for
the day of doing the camera.
- Yeah.
- Worst case scenario,
you're down by a day.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Or you just put up with
it and you're just like,
"I'm still gonna record even
though I feel like shit."
- Yeah.
- Well, we do that on Trash Taste.
(men chuckle)
- Is that today?
Is it today too?
- No, no, no, no, no.
I'm fine.
I mean there's some days obviously
where one of us is really
tired or one of us had,
they went out drinking
or something.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's like, "Ah, we gotta do it."
- Yeah, exactly.
- I think it's just like, you know?
- You just gotta turn
on your brain, right?
- If you were working on like,
a film set or something, or a TV show,
you don't get to be like, "Sorry, guys.
Feeling a little tired."
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You just gotta-
- You have to power through it.
- 'Cause now it's not
just us three, right?
And even then I would
still be like, "All right."
- [Daidus] Just do it.
- We have a bunch of staff
coming in, so it's like,
if one of us just doesn't turn
up or take care of ourselves,
it affects everyone.
- Yeah.
- True, you have a staff too.
- We have responsibility now for everyone.
- That's how I feel when
Meilyne brought us over
to GeeXPlus, I'm like, "Oh
great, well now I gotta work."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, but
it's a good motivator.
- I like it.
- It's like when you go to
a gym with a bro, right?
And you're spotting them
because you don't want to let
your bros down, right, you know?
- Yeah, 'cause you know,
you're at the gym, sometimes
you're like, "I'll skip the last set.
No one's gonna punish me."
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- If you're with your boy,
he's like, "What you doing?
We got one more set left"
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, you're
like, "Fuck, man, okay."
- All right, fine, I'll do it.
- I felt that, I felt that.
When I'm near you guys, or
over there, whatever, whatever.
I feel that and I appreciate it.
I'm like, "Oh, this is why."
There's three reasons why.
One, motivation.
- Yeah.
- And then two, food.
(Joey laughs)
- We all eat food.
(men laugh)
- That is true.
- I fucking love food.
- Okay.
- And then-
- I also love food.
- Yeah.
- Wow, what a hot take.
(all laugh)
- Probably the hottest
take on Trash Taste.
- The hottest on Trash Taste so far.
"I love food."
- Well, now there's different motivators
'cause now I have to pay for rent.
(all laugh)
- I gotta pay bills.
- [Daidus] I gotta pay bills.
- I find as a creator, when
you're around other people
who are very determined
and are making things
and being very proactive
and are really pushing
their content to the limits,
it very much influences me.
- [Daidus] Yeah, absolutely.
- I think we all stepped up our game
from being in Trash Taste,
and we all wanted to push
each other and make good stuff.
- I've definitely learned so much
just by being on Trash Taste
and just being with the boys
as well.
This year has been, I've been
outputting the most content
I've ever outputted in my entire career.
- I miss when you used to not post.
(men laughing)
I was like, "My brother."
(all laughing)
- That's how you know you can change, man.
That's how you know you can change.
I did, I did it!
I did it, man.
- You were the chosen one, Garnt.
(Garnt laughs)
- I remember, these two would post so fast
and I'm like, "I can't keep up."
This is years and years ago.
And when he was working at the BBC,
I could keep up with Garnt
because he would release
one video every three
months, and I'm like-
- Three months?
- It was once a year.
- Yeah, once a year, once
every six months maybe.
- It was a bunch of your-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It was like Dengy, he's
like, "He's just like me!"
- So you got sad that
Garnt upped his game?
- No, I mean, I'm glad for the boy.
(all laughing)
- What are you, his dad?
- I'm proud of you, son.
I'm proud of you, I'm proud of you.
- My pity.
(Garnt laughing)
- So if Garnt can do it, you can do it.
- So you want everyone to upload less?
You're like, "Please, guys.
Slow down, dude, slow down, guys."
- No.
But yeah, I got some new ideas to up the,
"Hey, guys, I'm still live."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Joey] Definitely.
- Especially with animations.
- 'Cause I'd say I've learned
a lot by being on Trash Taste
because it was like, the
process of this is so different
from being a non FleshTuber,
or what'd you call that?
I don't know what to call that.
- Virtual YouTube?
(all laughing)
- Avatuba.
- I don't know.
- Yeah, 'cause I was just a
disembodied voice, you know?
I had never showed my face or anything.
But all of my content, like
you, is very scripted, you know,
highly edited and stuff like that.
So I would have, you know,
aside from the drawing,
I would have a very similar process.
- I noticed that.
- Yeah, yeah.
And the big difference
between working on Trash Taste
and working with, you know,
live action videos is that
there is a clear separation
between, okay, work starts,
camera is on, you are working now.
Camera has stopped recording.
Job's over.
Video's done.
- Or like, "Oh, I messed up,
redo" Or whatever.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But there is a clear
separation to be like,
"Okay, my work here is
done, I can just relax."
Whereas with scripted videos
and with edited videos,
you're just like, "Oh, I could
maybe do a little bit more."
- Oh no, there's too much potential.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then you've got too
much, you waste too much time.
- Exactly, exactly.
There's no clear separation about
when you should start and
when the project is over.
Because there's always a
little bit you can do more.
There's things here and there.
- That's my biggest
problem with the videos,
is quality, quantity and stuff.
If it's quantity, I get too bored
'cause I'm not challenging myself.
If it's quality, I take too damn long.
- I'd be so scared to take
one month and just know that
it could not do well.
- I know, I know.
You know, I cry, every time
I upload a video, I'm like,
I'm dead.
I just, I cry, I don't actually
cry, but I'm just like,
I'm sad for like, two days.
- Why?
- But I pick myself up.
- Even if it does well?
- Because when you first
release it, you're like,
"What if nobody watches it?"
- Right.
- Right, right, right.
- And you wonder that for whatever,
but for some reason, animation,
it's trickling views.
- Yeah, with animation, it's
definitely more, you know,
it picks up really quickly
over a long period of time.
- Yeah, a long period of time.
- Where a lot of FleshTubing
videos, it's like,
(Garnt laughing)
FleshTube videos, not flesh tubing.
That was weird.
But with a lot of FleshTube videos,
like me and Connor, for example.
It's like, yeah, usually
it's within the first week
or something, it's the
majority of the views,
and then maybe every now and then
it'll kind of pick up,
you know, in the long run.
- Some videos just don't
stop getting views.
- Yeah, but I'd say, you know, I'd say,
I don't know about in your case,
but most videos it's the
first week is the peak, right?
- For sure, for sure.
In case you just get one
video that just seems to defy
all rules.
- Yeah.
- It's just so funny 'cause
sometimes Connor will be like,
"Oh, this video didn't perform well."
He gets sad.
I'm like, "Bro, you only took
a week to make that shit."
(all laughing)
I'm like, "Bro, sometimes
I'll take two months to make
one video."
- No, no, no, some videos
have taken me months,
and there's ones that
took me five minutes.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's like, the dichotomy
is shocking at times.
- He's not gonna be
like that with the video
he took five minutes to do.
- What we can share
together is that the fucking
YouTube studio is pure pain.
- Yeah, yeah.
- The rankings, one to ten.
- Yeah, the rankings.
- Why is it in the front?
Just hide that shit, bro.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, I completely agree,
it should not be front and center.
- [Connor] I wish there was an option
to completely turn it off.
- Yeah, just go away.
- They removed dislikes and
then they keep the fucking
one actual thing that
is actual detrimental
to my mental health front and center.
- I don't know a single person
that likes that feature.
I'm fine with it if you had to dig for it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
- Hide it in the menu, why
is it on the very front page?
- Why is it when I just wanna
see how my video's doing,
that's the first thing I have to see?
I'm forced to see it, you know?
- And it's like, "Oh, you're shit."
And then they're like,
"You're shit today."
Oh, okay.
- Just sucks 'cause I
guess if you upload a video
that doesn't do well for one whole month,
you gotta look at it.
- You get sad and you're
like, "Oh man, I suck."
- That's scary.
- I kind of intermittently
just remove the app
entirely from my phone,
especially if it's a video
that's, you know, a nine
out of 10 or something.
I was like, "I don't wanna
fucking look at this." (chuckles)
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Daidus] Right.
- So I just remove it from
my phone until my next video.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then if it does well
then I see the fireworks,
I was like, "All right,
installing that bitch again, baby."
- It sucks when you know
it's a video that's not gonna
do well as well, but you're
like, "Well, I like this video.
I'm gonna upload it.
I know people aren't gonna watch it,
or I know that YouTube's gonna kill it."
- Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- This episode is sponsored by Bokksu.
- Guys, it's time to touch some grass.
- Wait, what?
- What's up with you?
- You know the saying, "The
grass is always greener
on the other side" Right?
- Of course, yeah.
- Of course, of course.
- Well, not this time.
"What's on the other
side?" You might be asking.
well it's Bokksu.
- Oh my Lord, it was right here.
- [Connor] Bokksu is a
monthly subscription service
that delivers premium Japanese
snacks and tea pairings
straight from Japan to your door.
Each Bokksu features a new theme,
providing a gourmet journey through Japan
every single month.
- This month's Bokksu is in
the theme of Midori moments.
Do you guys know what Midori means?
- Joey, Midori is green in Japanese.
Do you get it now, guys?
(Joey speaks foreign language)
- Well, this is the uji
matcha waffle cookie.
- It's got two thick and crumbly
waffle cookies encased in
a smooth and rich matcha-infused
cream between their ridges.
- How's that?
- Oh, that's really good, actually.
- What I would personally
recommend is to pair this
with yuzu green tea, because
it's kind of got the,
sourness of the yuzu but the
mildness of the green tea.
Get all of these wonderful and delicious
matcha-flavored treats with
Bokksu and use our code,
"TRASHTASTE15" And the link
in the description below
to save $15 off your order.
- Mm, delicious.
- Back to the show.
- Animators or whatever.
I don't know what you call them.
I don't like being
called something because.
- Just Story Time people.
- No, because you call it Story
Time, the community is like,
(grunts)
Or like, "I'm a VTuber."
And then you get attacked
by the VTuber community.
- I think that's just like
any community in general.
- Just community in general,
the word, "Community"
Is always toxic no matter what.
- I've always just called
it Story Time animators.
- I'm just an artist, I don't know.
(men laughing)
- But I've noticed a lot of
Story Time animators are like,
they don't,
they don't post anymore, actually.
A lot of them.
They're all burnt out.
It's a burning out kind of medium.
- Well, they're kind of doing
other stuff, like Twitch
and you know all that.
- I mean, I get it, right?
- Twitch is like, it's feeding.
- If you're on a big boom, right?
And you're on a trend that's
absolutely crushing it,
and then suddenly you and all
your peers are making half
the money and you have to put in,
you have to put in
double the time for what,
half the money, half the views?
- [Daidus] It's like, triple the time.
- And then it's like, "All
right, well, what are we,
why am I doing this?"
- Yeah so a lot of the Story
Timers are trying to pivot.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm trying to pivot a little bit.
Just to have faster, feasible content.
- 'Cause I think, especially, you know,
with Story Time YouTubers,
because it takes so much work
and it's impossible to not
spend a month on this video
and pour your fucking heart
and soul into it, you know?
- Yeah, you have no lifeing.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Three weeks of no lifeing, I would say.
- Yeah, and that's a lot
to invest emotionally
if your video's not going to perform well.
- Yeah, exactly, and
that's what burns them out.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You know, you put three
weeks of the work in,
you got like, a thousand bucks.
- But that's why we try to
take any sponsors we can.
We're like, "Please."
- Right, right.
- 'Cause I mean, if you did
three weeks worth of work
in a very specialized
industry, and they gave you
a thousand bucks for doing insane hours.
- I'm gonna be honest, I
would probably quit by now
if I didn't get sponsors.
It's like, it's not worth it.
- I hate when people are
like, "Oh, it's 'cause you,
you're not doing it for the art."
It's like, "Fuck no, dude,
I'm trying to pay rent."
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Easy enough to say that when you live
with your parents, right?
- Yeah, in the start it
was pure, it was like,
"Yeah, I'm doing this because-"
- 'Cause it's a hobby.
- 'Cause I love doing it.
And I still do enjoy doing it.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I do enjoy doing it, but the thing is,
I enjoy doing it, but if
I can't pay rent with it,
I can't do it.
I've gotta go and get a
job and then I'll upload
once every four months.
- [Daidus] My man.
- It's not even that nowadays either.
It's like, you know, "I also
need to pay my fucking editor."
I need to pay people who
help me in shoots, you know?
It's not just me anymore.
- It's annoying too,
because for some reason,
live actioners, they get a-
- [Connor] FleshTuber.
- FleshTuber.
They get a pass for it
when they do sponsors,
and then when animators
do it, it's just like,
- Really?
- "What happened
to the passion?"
- Really?
- [Joey] Really?
- Not anymore.
It used to.
- I think that used to be for everyone.
- Yeah, that used to be for everyone.
If your sponsor wasn't directly involved
with your content in some
way, then it was like,
"Oh, you're such a fucking sellout."
- I remember when.
I remember when Patreon.
Yeah, I remember when
Patreon first launched.
And anyone who got a
Patreon was just like,
"Wow, I can't believe you sold out.
my God.
You think I'm going to
fucking donate to you?
Stop E-begging, you mother fucker."
They called it, "E-begging."
And it was just like, it's
nice that the mentality
has completely changed
over time to now be like,
"Oh, this video's not got a sponsor?
Yo, you paying rent okay, bro?"
You know?
Sponsors are completely normal now.
- [Daidus] Thank God.
- Nowadays, if you'd see
a sponsored video, there'd
always be that comment
being like, "Damn, Joey
getting that bread today."
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They're encouraging about it.
- [Daidus] It's very different.
- Five years ago, nothing like that.
- Not even five years ago.
It was like, three years ago.
- Yeah, a couple years ago it
was like, nothing like that
was around, so it's like,
it's just so weird now
that it's almost like, I don't know,
congratulated in a sense?
- I think it's just more
become more accepted
that being a YouTuber is
a job, and not just a job,
but a career, you know?
And we require sponsors in
order to keep the show running,
and I think people have now
more accepted that YouTube
is one of the main forms of entertainment
that a lot of people watch.
- [Joey] But I think that's
the thing, it's like, I think now that
the majority of the
understanding is that a YouTuber
getting sponsored means
that there's gonna be
better quality shit.
- [Daidus] Quality has gone up.
- Sometimes, sometimes.
Sometimes they just want the money.
- Yeah, sometimes they just
want the money, of course,
but I think the general
understanding is like,
"Oh, they're going to use this
money to up their quality,
or up their content in
whatever way" Right?
- Yeah.
- Well, the first job of being a YouTuber
is making it sustainable and making it
so you can support yourself,
and a lot of the times
you can't support
yourself without a Patreon
or without sponsors, you know?
There are some forms of
content, like animators,
which have like, you guys
have a much harder time
generating revenue when
you upload once a month.
- Yeah, why didn't any of the,
I never really saw any
of the Story Time people
getting Patreons.
I never really saw it much.
- That's the thing, most
animators, or most artists,
they hate making money
because it makes them feel bad
because it's like, "Oh, I'm
selling out to the devil.
My passion."
And I used to be like that.
- [Joey] Right.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- But then lately I'm like,
"Bro, I, can't do this anymore."
- Bro, passion only
takes you so long, man.
- And then you're like,
"Shit, actually you know what?
This passion thing's looking shit.
- We still enjoy it, obviously.
- Of course, yeah.
- We would've quit a long time ago.
- But passion doesn't pay the bills.
- It's just nice, it's like, "Bro."
- But even passion doesn't get
you through those hard days
where you're just like, "I
don't want to work today, man,
but I gotta upload something."
- Especially, we had to draw a line.
You know sometimes even drawing a line.
- "I'm going for a beer."
- A single line and say, "I'm done."
- I'm serious, I'm serious.
Even setting up the whole tablet thing
and drawing a line, it sometimes is tough.
- I get it, I get it.
- I don't wanna draw a line.
I don't wanna draw a line today.
- Only circles.
- No, it's like, I get it
'cause sometimes I'm just like,
"I don't wanna watch anime today."
But I've kind of got to, you know?
- Oh, yeah, for your job?
- Yeah, and I'm like, "How
can you complain about fucking
watching anime or reading manga?"
I'm like, "That sounds
like an amazing job."
And I'm just like-
- Most of it's shit.
(Garnt laughs)
- I do watch a lot of shit as well.
- How do you do it?
You have a technique?
You only watch three
episodes or something?
- I have a technique.
- It's called sight.
- He's watching four at once.
(Joey laughs)
- I actually, some shows I
watch on times two speed, yeah.
That has been the life saver for me.
- That's me with YouTube.
Every video I watch, two times speed.
- [Connor] What?
- Yeah.
- What?
- Every YouTube video?
- Because I think about it like,
if I think about it.
Okay, 40 minute long
video, two times speed,
that's 20 minutes.
I saved 20 minutes.
- Yeah, but can you not,
'cause I've done that before
as well, just to test it out.
Half the videos I watch,
I don't understand
what the fuck's happening.
It's too fast.
- If you do it enough, your
brain can be like, "Ah."
(Joey laughs)
- You're commodifying entertainment.
You're turning it into a challenge.
- Okay, it depends.
- It's just talking, right?
- Like a Family Guy speed run.
- It depends, right, it depends.
If there's a video in which
I am just trying to get
information out of this video,
like a tutorial or
maybe I'm like watching,
you know, Philly D and I'm just like,
"I just want to hear the news said to me,
I just need to consume information."
- How do you listen to
Philly D at two time speed?
He talks at two times
speed at one time speed.
- So you watch entertainment
in two times speed?
- No, no, only if they're
talking, most of the time.
If the visuals are, you know,
animation or, I don't know,
something visually.
- If they're talking?
That's everything ever.
- Yeah, yeah, that's most of YouTube.
They're talking so much,
so two times speed.
- Netflix, you're watching
it on two times speed?
- No.
- So why YouTube and not Netflix?
- I feel like YouTube is
more background consumable
kid of content.
And Netflix is like, "I
wanna sit down on my couch
and watch something."
- Yeah, yeah, I get it.
- You don't watch that kind
of Netflix-styled content
on YouTube at all?
You don't watch documentary videos?
- I only watch YouTube on two times speed.
- Yeah.
- What the fuck?
- I get it because-
- I'm gonna make my
videos two times slower.
(all laugh)
- But that's the thing.
when I take off two times
speed, I go to normal speed,
I'm like, "Why is this so slow?"
- Why is it like a normal
human conversation?
God forbid.
- I've gotten to the point
with some videos, right?
I'm on your team here, I'm on your team.
- Thank you.
- [Connor] I could not.
- I've gotten to the point
where sometimes you just,
you play a video and you
forget which speed it's at
and you have to check.
It's like, "Is this normal speed or two,
oh, it's 1.5 times speed."
I've forgotten what a normal
speaking pace is right now.
Because everyone talks at a
different pace, but I like
the same tempo with everyone
I listen to, I guess.
- You're the reason why we'll end up with
the Wall-E movie, dude, why
we'll end up in the spaceship.
People like you.
- These guys think like Sonic, you know?
- Just consuming, not
ever enjoying anything.
- I enjoy it!
- Wall-E was right, dude.
- I do enjoy it.
- What information am I leaving out?
Nothing.
I'm still listening to the whole video.
- Dude, imagine the cinematographer
went to all this effort
to set up the shot, and he's
like. (vocalizes skipping tape)
It's like, "Bro, what the fuck?"
- 20 minutes is like a walk to the deli.
- There are some videos
that need to be watched
at fucking 1.5.
- I agree, there are tutorials
and there's stuff like that where-
- It's not just tutorials.
- Sometimes people talk
too slow, but 99% of videos
should just be watched in the
fucking speed they intended.
- Yeah.
- I think it's about 50/50.
- To me, it's about 50/50.
There are some pieces of content-
- Give me an example.
- Yeah, I'm not saying I
watch all two times speed.
- Drama videos where you just
hear about news with other
fucking creators or whatever,
that is not something
I need to watch at one time speed, man.
- That and tutorial videos are
the only ones I can think of.
- And if you're watching a
documentary or something,
that's one time speed, you know?
If it's heavily edited, you
know, it's one time speed.
If it's just a guy.
- Yeah, I agree.
- If it's a guy in front of
a camera just talking about
a topic or something, I'm like-
- I just don't watch those videos.
- I just don't watch those. (laughs)
- You watch a lot more of those videos
than you think you do.
- Or maybe at 1.25 or 1.5.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Do you watch ASMR
videos at two times speed?
- [Daidus] I don't watch ASMR.
- 1.25 I can kind of
get a little bit behind,
but 2 is just too fast.
- 1.5.
- Yeah, no, no,
to me, two is-
- 1.75. (laughs)
- [Connor] Oh my God.
- So two, I haven't gotten to
the two times speed meta yet,
I guess. (chuckles)
- We must go beyond. (laughs)
- I can't believe people
just look at the timestamp
and they're like, "I can go faster."
They're like, "I want to do this faster."
- Hey, you saved 20
minutes, that's a trip,
that's a poop session right there.
- Is your objective to just consume more?
What are you trying to achieve by-
- I'm not trying to consume
more, I'm just like...
- If it's background noise,
what's the problem with
leaving it at one time speed?
- Well, okay, it depends on-
- Surely it must sound
like fucking penis music
in the background?
- It depends on how into the topic.
If I'm into the topic, two times speed.
- You said you used to watch-
- If I'm not, I'll make
it slow so I can draw
in the background.
- You said you used to watch Trash Taste
before you felt like it was parasocial.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my God, the Parasocial
was fucking poodle, man.
I couldn't do it.
- Did you watch Trash
Taste in two times speed?
- I tried it, I was like,
"Emily, let's watch it
at 1.5 speed."
She's like, "No."
- No, because, to me, if I'm watching it-
- [Connor] I was gonna say,
I was like, "Don't you dare."
- To be fair, if I'm
watching at 1.5 speed,
I'm paying attention,
so I'm very consciously
paying attention.
If it's in the background, it
has to be at one time speed.
But so yeah, to me, it's just
like, yeah, you are consuming.
You are consuming this content,
and that's why I watch it
at 1.5 to 2 times speed, whatever.
But there is some content that is,
it's technically entertainment,
but the entertainment
is getting the information
that this person
is portraying, I guess.
I don't know, it's really weird, right?
It's really weird.
- That's the funny part is
that if I am alone, though,
I will watch Trash Taste
at two times speed.
- God damn it.
- How dare you?
- Guess what?
A two hour long video, I save an hour.
- I guess it's better than
Mulan who edits this shit
at four times speed.
- Are you just sitting
there doing nothing else,
watching Trash Taste?
- No, I'm listening.
- Can you listen at two
times speed and still
do something else?
There's no fucking way.
- [Joey] I can't hear
anything in two times speed.
- Listen, listen, you
ever done that thing-
- [Connor] They'd have flying cars by now
if you could do that.
- When you read a whole book
and it flashes the words
really fast, and you
could read the whole book?
- What the fuck are you talking about?
- [Daidus] You ever seen that?
There's a thing, an image or whatever.
- Yeah.
- They say like, "Oh, you can
read this book really fast
if you just flash the words like."
It's the same thing.
- What are you talking about?
- If you watch too much two
times speed, you get used to it
and it's like normal.
- You're saying you can speed
up the brain's processing?
- Yeah.
(Daidus and Garnt laugh)
Overclock.
- You're overclocking your brain.
(Garnt laughs)
- What is this, fucking Limitless?
- The limitless advice is saying, "Man"
And watching this stuff
at two times speed.
- Whoa.
- Just watching everything
at times two speed.
- There's gotta be some people
out there that's like me, come on, man.
- No, I'm sure there are,
but it's just, that's not me.
- That's why it's a feature
on YouTube, you know?
It wouldn't be a feature
if a lot of people
weren't using it, you know?
- Yeah.
- At the same time, there must
be some people who can only
watch videos at .5 speed.
- Oh dude, that's-
- That sounds terrible.
- No, no, no.
That's, yeah.
- Maybe they take a while to process.
- Or maybe if you don't speak
English very well, you know,
it's your second language.
- I mean, some Philly D videos
I have to watch at .5 speed
'cause I'm like, "You're
talking too fast."
- Really?
- Figuratively.
- I'm like, "I wish I could."
- Philly D is like, 1.75.
- He's like, "It's not quite two."
- "It's not quite two."
- He talks very fast.
- I'm getting a brain
aneurysm hearing this.
- Just sounds like white
noise after a while.
(Connor mumbling)
- Oh my God.
- Well, I mean, it's just like,
you know how when you read
manga you can pick the pace
you're reading at, right?
So everyone has a different pace, right?
- Yeah, I'm very slow with mangas.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I like the art.
- So the way I see it is that it's just,
you're picking the pace
in which you are able to
get this information, 'cause
why is it any different
from speeding through a few
pages versus some people
who really wanna look at
the artwork and you know,
appreciate what's being
drawn, and some people
are just like, "All right,
there we go" You know?
That's how I see it.
- I think 'cause it's the
difference between the treadmill
and the exercise bike, right?
The treadmill you pick the
speeds and then you've gotta try
and keep up with it, whereas
the bike is as fast as you can
make it go.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- That's a good analogy.
- It's not the same action, right?
'Cause you're reading and
it's like you are putting in
effort to read this thing,
so obviously you can push it.
But if the treadmill's going
too fast, you can't keep up.
- Well, you're not reading
a manga and it's like,
"You have 20 seconds
before the page explodes."
- No, but what I am saying
is, if you set it at a speed
where you can keep up then.
- Well, which reminds me.
- Yeah?
- Speaking of pacing
and poop, pooping.
(Joey and Garnt chuckle)
- Go on.
Go on.
- That was the weirdest fucking
tangent I've ever heard.
- [Joey] Go on, I'm listening.
- So I take my sweet
time on the toilet, okay?
- Yes, I am also a dude.
- The heated toilet.
- [Joey] Of course, yeah.
- And now the bidet.
- Yeah.
- Oh, God, dude,
You gotta hear this.
- It's a fucking amazing.
(Garnt and Connor laugh)
- Wait, but first.
So Emily pees longer than
she poops, I swear to God.
I say this a lot, but I swear it's true.
And she's like, "Why do you poop so long?"
And it's because, it's the best time.
I love pooping.
- I agree.
- I agree, I love it as well.
- What made you bring this up?
- Oh, because I heard
poop and I heard pacing.
- I did not say poop.
- You said...
(Garnt laughs)
- I did not say poop.
- You said poop.
- Mulan, rewind the clip.
I did not say poop.
- You know what?
Okay, there was poop and then manga,
'cause I read my manga on the toilet.
- [Joey] Right.
- I only read manga on the toilet.
So then when you said manga,
I thought of bathroom.
(Garnt laughs)
- That doesn't mean he said poop.
- This is some weird
Pavlov's dog kind of thing.
He's reading and he just wants to shit.
- This is like that scene
where Sherlock is picking
the fucking words out of the
air, you know what I mean?
It's like, "pacing, poop, manga."
It's like, "I can make this a tangent."
- Pacing because everybody
takes their time on the toilet
or not.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Joey] I get that.
- And I love the toilet.
- And I do too, I agree.
- He comes over to my house, right?
And he's like, "Oh"-
- Oh, no.
- "Which bidet thing do I press?"
- Right.
- And I was like, "You press
the one that like says oshiri."
- Yeah, it has an asshole on it.
- Yeah, it has an ass, right?
And he's like, "Oh, I've
been pressing all of them."
I'm like, "What do you
mean, you've been pressing
all of them?"
And he's like, "Oh, I thought
it was like a course."
Like a bidet course meal.
- Three course meal.
- And I'm like, "What do you mean?"
He's like, "Yeah, 'cause
one of them's hard,
one of them's soft and
then one of the does
a different area."
- I'm like, "Why?"
- One of them's for
cleaning the ass cheeks.
- And he was pressing the
bidet and then pressing
the ass cleaning.
- You were doing the vagina one as well?
- Yeah, I didn't know
that was the vagina one.
I thought the picture looked
like it splashes your butt.
- Yeah.
- So I thought it was like,
one is for the inside,
and the one for for it is the soft inside
after you wipe once.
(Garnt laughs)
And then the third one is
cleaning your ass cheeks
in case you got poop all
over your ass cheeks.
- He genuinely said this.
- How violent are your shits?
- No, no, I don't do it
anymore, now that Connor told me
that it wasn't a-
- That's the reason why
Daidus is on the toilet,
'cause he's having a three course meal.
- He's literally did, he's eating a three,
I've never heard Daidus
mention a course before, ever,
about meals or anything.
He's never been interested in it,
but suddenly bidet courses exist.
- Bidet courses.
- And I'm like, "What, you
wear a tux to the toilet?
What's going on?"
- It's like, "Let see the
menu, let me see your menu.
Oh, we got four courses today."
- You saw three and you're
like, "Oh, it must be a course."
- Yeah, yeah.
How would I know?
It's in Japanese!
- On screen, here is
the thing, and this one,
the one that says, "Oshiri"
Is the one for your butt.
- Yeah, that's all you need to press.
And then stop, obviously.
- Obviously the other one is for-
- [Garnt] That's the fourth course.
- Yeah, that's the ending,
that's the finisher.
- The one that says "Bidet"
Which you might think,
'cause obviously it's called a
bidet, it's actually just for
the woman's parts.
- The lady's part.
- Yeah, the lady part.
- Longest time I thought
was called bidget.
I kept saying bidget.
- Bidget. (laughs)
Bid it.
- It was just such a funny
thing 'cause he was just like,
it was so wholesome.
He was like, "I'm using
the three course meal."
(all laugh)
- So yeah, is the bidet
one of your favorite things
about Japan?
- It is.
- [Joey] Hell yeah.
- Oh, and the bathroom.
The hot tub.
I mean, not the hot tub-
- The hot tub?
- But the tub.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- The tub that becomes hot.
- Japanese baths are so fucking good.
- 'Cause I remember Emily
said that you take a bath
every day.
- Yeah, and now I'm watching
Netflix in it, I'm like.
- Dude, it's the best.
It's the fucking best.
- And I get drinking.
- Feeling like a king?
- It's very nice.
- [Connor] The baths are amazing.
- Because in America, you
don't want to take a bath
because you shower in the same bath.
- [Joey] Right.
- So it gets nasty, and
then you're sharing it.
- I have to say, every
single bath I've ever been in
in someone's house in the US looks vile.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It looks disgusting.
- Yeah.
- But that's 'cause they don't use it.
- It's just the place to stand.
- And people don't wash
their bathtubs much
in the US, right?
- No, well, I don't know, my mom does.
It depends if they're Asian or not.
(Joey laughs)
- If one of your parents is
Asian, they clean the bath.
- I've never had a friend be
like, "Yo, I was just cleaning
my bathtub."
I've never had that before.
- My mom.
- Yeah, Asian mom is like-
- Does your family take baths though,
or are they just cleaning it just for the?
Oh, they're just cleaning it?
- Well, yeah, because it looks nasty,
but there's still scuffs
that you can't remove ever.
It's just there for ever,
and you're looking at it
while you're showering, you're like.
- Yeah.
- I bathed a lot in the UK.
We had a bath, separate.
They had no shower or anything.
- [Daidus] Oh, really?
- Yeah.
- Did you clean the bath?
- No, my mom did.
- No, no, I just meant
in general. (chuckles)
- I mean, no, I didn't
until I came to Japan.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I was like, "Why do
I feel crust on my baths?"
- Ugh.
- The grease build up.
- Yeah, yeah, the grease is gross.
- So you gotta clean it.
I know Japanese people
clean it every time?
They give it a quick scrub, right?
Normally.
- Yeah, yeah, my mom, at home
used to do a quick scrub of it
and then fill the bath.
- I do it every like, two,
three weeks if I'm feeling,
you know, until I notice something.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- When I feel something
then I'm like, "All right,
time to clean."
- When you put your finger
against like.
- Yeah 'cause you can put
your finger against it
and it isn't smooth.
- Yeah.
- And then you gotta clean it.
- Sure, sure, sure.
- It's not anything bad.
You can't see anything,
you can just feel it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well sometimes you just
gotta clean up the bathroom
period, right?
Because unfortunately just gunk builds up.
- Dude, wet rooms are the best.
I dunno why you'd ever want a room-
- Yeah, I agree.
- That you just can't get-
- It's amazing.
- I just want, you know.
- Wet rooms?
- The Japanese showers are like wet rooms.
- Oh, oh, okay, okay.
- You can put stuff on the floor.
in America, if you put
something on the floor,
you might damage your house.
- Like all the mist and
stuff stays in the bath,
so you can go out.
- Dude, automatic fill.
- So you don't have the mold.
- Yeah?
- You say you don't have
the mold build up sometimes.
Yeah, yeah, that is really good, yeah.
- The auto fill on the bath is amazing.
You can choose the
temperature and the level.
- And it talks to you.
- And the time as well.
You can set that shit to be
like, "Fill it up at 6 am."
- I just don't understand
why we don't have that
in the UK or the US.
Why would we not want-
- 'Cause not enough people
take baths, I guess.
- They would if you had a, "Oh,
you're getting up at 6:50am?
You want a bath set for that time
at this exact temperature?"
- I'm saying like, bidets,
why is that not normalized worldwide?
- It's catching on in America.
It's becoming a bigger thing.
- Catching on, but it's just like,
I think in America it's just
quick, quick, quick, quick.
Take your five minute shower and get out.
- But my baths aren't that long.
- I just like the fact that
you can stand on the floor
and be like, "Oh, this is fine."
- Yeah.
- You step on the floor in
America, you're like, "Oh."
- [Joey] Everything's wet.
- Yeah, everything's wet.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's not good.
- Yeah 'cause I remember
the absolute state
of British toilets, right?
I remember I go to one public
restroom, and you know,
and this was just the day
that I landed as well.
And this thing, forget not having a bidet,
this didn't even have a toilet seat.
I shit you not, right?
- That happens, that happens.
- Yeah, I just went in and I was like,
I was expecting at least a
toilet seat and it just like,
"Oh my God, this is the
most depressing sight
I've ever seen.
Oh my God."
- You do the squats?
- Yeah, basically.
- Free leg days when you take a shit.
- An absolute state.
Absolute state.
- God, so gross.
- But you told me before
that, because you are so happy
with the bidets because
before you wiped so hard that
you were starting bleeding and shit.
I'm like, "What?!"
- Well, in America-
- I've done that.
- I like to do this thing.
I get made fun of, I don't know why,
but I do wet, dry, wet, dry.
I put my toilet paper
in the sink to make it
a little bit wet so I'll get
the wet to pick up the poop
and then dry to clean
it, and I go back to wet
and I go back to dry.
Well, that's a lot, you know, it's a lot.
- Yeah, no wonder you're
doing the course meal,
you were doing that before.
- [Daidus] I would like to say-
- You were self-bideting before.
- Bro, I have the cleanest
asshole in America.
(all laughing)
I like my asshole clean.
- I bet you do.
- Thank you very much.
- I mean like, yeah, I've
definitely never heard of that.
That's funny.
- What is that?
How did you come up with this?
- Yeah, did you just
figure that out yourself?
- The wet picks up poop
and then the dry cleans it.
- So wait, how did you,
you know, damage it?
- Have you ever used wet wipes?
- I guess if you wipe too
much on cheap toilet paper
or something.
- Yeah.
- Then your asshole stinks.
It's not bleeding, but it stinks.
- Stinks? (laughs)
- It stinks.
- That means something is
definitely going wrong.
- That usually means poop is afoot.
- No, the bidet, never stinks ever, ever,
'cause I don't have to wipe that much.
- Because you just blasted
your ass with water.
- Yeah, it's amazing.
- Have you ever used wet
wipes on your ass then?
If you're wetting the-
- I read online that wet
wipes is bad for your asshole.
(Garnt laughs)
- It's also bad for the sewage system.
- It's just bad.
- Yeah.
- I don't know.
- This is the first I'm hearing
that it's bad for your ass.
- Yeah, why is it bad for your ass?
- I don't know, I Googled it one time.
- Maybe the alcohol ones?
- Well no, but there's
wet wipes that don't have
alcohol in them.
- Yeah, you got the baby wipes, right?
Which is literally for the ass.
- It's just Google, they
think everything's bad, so.
- That's true.
- Oh, happiness?
That's bad, actually.
That's too much happiness.
- Oh, you have depression.
Crippling depression.
You're sad forever now.
- I mean, I'm sure baby wipes, right?
Wet baby wipes would be all right.
That was the same way.
- It seems more effective
than having a three course
where you wet.
- You're reaching over
to the sink, you know?
- Could you reach the sink from the toilet
in your previous house?
- Yeah, most of the time.
- I was gonna say, 'cause
are you pre-wetting it?
- No, the sink's right here's so you just.
- Oh, okay, so I was
gonna say, I was wondering
if you're pre-wetting a bunch
and then going to court.
- Well, sometimes when I go
to a friend's house, I'm like,
"Oh, dang, their sink's
far away" You know?
- So what do you do?
- I'll pre wet a bunch.
Not a bunch, maybe one or two, and then-
- What if you need more?
- Well, if my asshole's almost clean,
but not completely
clean, I'll waddle over.
(men laughing)
Then waddle back.
- Your friends are never
inviting you over again.
Thank God you don't do that anymore.
- I have a clean asshole, I
don't know what to tell you.
- It's like, "Bro, give
me, bring me some wet
toilet paper stat.
My ass stinks."
- Yeah.
- So yeah, is this the first
time you've shown your face
on camera?
Is this the face reveal?
- For a long time.
- No, you showed your face, right?
- When?
- When you did the eating noodles thing.
- Oh yeah.
Was that in your mom's basement?
- Yeah, that was my mom's basement.
- [Joey] Okay.
- Yeah, so that was a day
before, not even a day,
I was gonna have to take the
plane within like, three hours.
And I'm going to AX.
That's when I met you guys.
- Oh, okay, okay.
- And I'm like, "Well,
if I'm gonna go, I need,
at least some people to like, you know,
recognize me I guess."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I was like, "What can I"-
- You need people to recognize you?
"What am I gonna do with no clout?"
- No, it just makes it more fun.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Especially when you
have other creator friends
that are like, "You're that guy."
- Yeah, to be fair, I didn't
know what you looked like
when I met you.
- Yeah, me neither.
- I just knew about you.
- Yeah 'cause I was just like,
I would suggest anyone
who's starting YouTube
to don't hide your face forever.
- [Connor] Just show it?
- Yeah, just show it right off the bat
because the expectation was so high.
- Yeah, right, right, right.
- Nothing I could have
done would've been able
to deal with it.
So I was just like, "I'm just
gonna record a shitty ass
video of me eating
ramen and I'm just gonna
fucking upload it."
- You had the Hyper
Cam logo in the corner.
- Yeah, well, I photoshopped that myself.
- Yeah, I saw, I saw.
- Well, what I loved about
that face reveal video
was that the room was so dark
and the quality was so shit,
you couldn't see your face. (laughs)
You had to squint being like,
"He's in there somewhere."
- "I think he's white,
I think he's white."
- "I think he's white."
- Yeah, I guess that was
when I was, you know,
I was presentable.
Now I just got fatter and I'm like,
"Fuck, I don't wanna
show my face anymore."
Especially during COVID, I
was like, "Fuck, I'm fat.
I'm gonna hide."
- You look fine, man, you look fine.
- Well, for now.
I've been doing like,
- You look good, man.
- 10,000 steps a day in
Japan, which is like...
- Which is standard.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- In the United States,
you have to drive everywhere, so.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly, exactly.
- I'm happy about that.
- And did you get a lot of
people coming up to you at AX
during that time?
'Cause I never really
asked you about that.
- Decent amount.
The thing is, like I said, my hyper cam
was very hard to see, so
sometimes I'd be like, "Hey!"
- You literally had the fucking,
you know when they're like,
"Have you seen this man?"
And it's always 1p footage
of the crime happening.
That was literally your face real.
- It's funny 'cause I did have blue hair,
but it didn't pick up in the video.
- You did have blue hair on that video.
- 'Cause you were wearing
your hat as well, right?
- You uploaded on Instagram
a picture of you and me
and I was so drunk that
day that when you did that,
I looked at it and I was
like, "I don't remember this."
- No, because it was at the FAKKU party,
and I hadn't watched
your face reveal video
at the time, right?
'Cause you know, I was
obviously getting prepared
for AX and shit.
And then yeah, I was
just kinda hanging out,
and then I just hear like, "Hey, Joey!"
- Oh, I think 'cause I talked to Connor.
- Yeah, I was like, "Go talk to Joey."
- Yeah, and you ran over,
and at first I was like,
and you know, you came over and was like,
"Yeah, what's up, man?"
And I was like, "Who is this guy?"
(men laughing)
But then I heard the voice
and I was like, "Oh."
- Dude, which reminds me, that's so crazy.
The voice, I don't-
- You have a really iconic voice.
- I didn't know it was like-
- Distinguished voice.
- Before I even did the
face reveal on my channel,
I went to Chipotle in Maine, and I went up
and I went to get my order.
I was scuffed.
I had a full beard.
I was in my pajamas.
And I was like, "Could I
get a large burrito steak?"
- Right.
- And the lady, the cashier,
well, the burrito lady was
like, "Are you a YouTuber?"
And I was like, "No."
(all laugh)
Because I was too embarrassed.
I didn't wanna.
- I think your way of
talking is very noticeable.
- Yeah.
- I feel bad for Corpse Husband.
You can't even go out
with him, it'd be like,
"Is that Corpse?"
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I can't even imagine.
- That's what I'm saying like,
when you hide your face,
the expectation's too high.
It sucks a lot of poo poo.
- Back to that.
- Thank you for that.
- I thought you liked poop? (laughs)
- I like pooping.
(Garnt laughs)
- No, because the first time
Daidus and I interacted,
he made an animation for
me, way back when you had
50 subs or something, right?
- Oh yeah, I was very desperate.
(Joey laughs)
And I didn't know how to
talk to big creators really.
So I was like, "Do I talk
to him in a friendly way
or do I do it like business
or do I do whatever?"
And I was asking my dad, I'm like,
"How do I interact with
a big YouTuber?" Whatever
- 'Cause your dad would know.
- Like your dad knows the answer.
- No, he doesn't, and
he's just like. (mumbles)
So I tried different
things and I was like,
"This is fucking cringe."
The last email I sent was so cringe.
- Really?
I don't even remember.
- Oh, good, because you didn't
reply to it, and I'm like,
I'm like (breathing rapidly)
(all laugh)
- No, because I remember
when you made that animation
for me, and you obviously,
you know, put your narration.
- Oh and it got demonetized.
- Yeah, it got demonetized,
but I remember,
'cause you put your narration
into it as well, right?
And your friend, Send's
narration was in that as well.
- [Daidus] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And you know, and I was
like, "Man, this guy's voice
is really unique."
- [Daidus] Why?
- I don't know, it was
something about the way you,
I don't know, how do you
describe Daidus' voice?
It's interesting inflections.
- Yeah.
- In different words.
- I don't have enough descriptors
to be able to describe
someone's voice.
- Your tone of voice is,
you know, pretty standard,
but it's your inflection in your voice.
When you talk, it's very-
- When I go, high like this?
- Yeah, I don't know-
- You don't do that.
- I remember, I didn't really,
I mean, I was okay with
my voice usually, and then I
had an ex-girlfriend that said
my voice made me sound dumb.
And I took that to heart.
I was like, "Am I
actually, do I sound dumb?"
- No.
- Then but later, on YouTube
the comments would be like,
"I love your voice."
And I'm like, "So, I'm okay?" (chuckles)
- No, no, you're fine, you're fine.
I don't know, it's a very
unique quality that I think,
you know, you've obviously
used to your strength.
- Yeah.
- Obviously it's a very good thing.
- I didn't even know that
was a strength though.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- To tell your stories.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- You can hear a Daidus
video when you hear it.
- Yeah, exactly.
- It's immediately like,
"Yeah, that's Daidus."
- Squid neutral.
- Yeah, exactly.
- It's only an advantage
if you don't show your face
as well, because that means
your voice is so distinct,
and it helps set you apart
from any other person
who doesn't show their face, you know?
- Showing your face is a little
sketchy, 'cause it's like,
will this affect my channel?
Will this affect how people see me?
- Probably not though really.
I mean there's not many-
- Because I didn't really
pretend to be someone.
- If you're doing something
concerning or something that
people think is widely not accepted.
You know, you're doing sexual things.
A lot of people,
unfortunately they judge you
quite harshly for that.
- That's like VTubers, isn't it?
- I guess, a lot of them just want it
for the privacy though, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's not that it's shameful.
It's not that it's
shameful, they're not like,
"I make anime."
"I know, I'm one of the worst of society."
- There's so many sexualized VTubers now.
- I guess if you're, if you're being,
you wouldn't be that sexual
if your face was maybe shown.
I don't know, but I mean, the
point is is that there are
a lot of reasons why it's totally valid.
- It breaks the, my
immersion, my immersion.
- Yeah, yeah.
(everyone laughs)
- I feel like I've done this
so long though that like,
fuck it.
- Yeah, I mean, I think
you mentioned VTubers,
but I think it just,
every VTuber is different.
They've cultivated a different
kind of audience as well.
So very much-
- It got toxic.
- Yeah, yeah, so it very much depends on
the kind of audience you
cultivate, and you know.
- There's a lot of V-Tubers
who have shown their faces.
- Some just also don't wanna
show their face, which is like,
obviously, that's totally fine.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, because it's
the fucking internet, right?
And you know, especially nowadays,
privacy is a fucking massive
thing on the internet
where I feel like a lot
of people are entitled
to know what someone looks like, you know?
- And you know, obviously, you know,
they might go to a
Chipotle and get recognized
by their voice, but
that's something they just
have to figure out, 'cause
that's their choice, you know?
- Yeah, like I said, you
mentioned Corpse Husband.
I feel so sorry for Corpse
Husband 'cause there's-
- Just going to to the grocery store.
- No, there's just fucking-
- [Joey] There's one that sounds like him.
- There's fucking people
who are basically hiring
private detectives to find
out what he looks like
and shit, right?
- Dude, how does he leave his house?
I don't even know.
- I'm just like, "Oh my God."
- It's like that chick who
got a tattoo of the wave form
of him breathing into the mic and shit.
- Oh my God, yeah, yeah.
How'd even handle that kind of-
- How'd you go out?
And talk at all?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's so crazy.
He probably has to just say like,
he just has to write on notes.
Being like, "Can I have
a big burrito, please?"
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
Yeah, so it's tough.
- Have you ever thought
about incorporating your face
into your content more?
- Be a FleshTuber?
You wanna join the FleshTuber gang?
- Just be more casual about it, I guess?
- It'd be nice to post faster, but,
I'll think about it.
I definitely wanna try
different things though
with animating, drawing and stuff.
- Streaming or anything like that?
- I do wanna do streaming.
I made a VTuber model
myself, which is cool.
It was very hard to learn.
Was it 2D live or something?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, live 2D.
- You did it all on stream?
- Yeah, I did it.
It took me like, I don't
know, a week or two.
Only took me long because I
was taking my sweet time, but.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then I got another
model going on, so,
we'll play around with that, and then.
I mean, if I show myself on camera enough,
people will get used
to it and I'll be like,
"Okay, I can show my face."
- Yeah.
- Every time I'm doing stuff
with Connor or you guys
and I'm on camera, it's like,
"That's what Daidus looks like?
Whoa, what the fuck?"
You know, I'm always getting those.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I guess it'll
just take a bit of time
for your audience to get used to it.
Once they're used to it,
I don't think there'll be
any problems at all.
- Yeah, I mean, even though I
showed my face at the end of
every one of my videos, it
was only after I started
being on Trash Taste
that people were like,
"Oh, that's what he looks like."
And I'm just like, "Motherfucker,
I've been showing my face
for years" You know?
Everyone just clicked off before the end
so nobody saw before.
So, yeah, so where'd you
think the future of Story Time
animators are gonna go now?
What's the field like right now?
'Cause you said it was like, not as,
not at its peak like it was before.
- I feel like, well, for the most part,
it's a lot of kid audience.
- Yeah.
- I've always, from the
beginning, tried to stray away
from the kid friendly.
I'll be like PG, maybe PG 13.
Never rated R or whatever,
because I don't wanna
establish myself as like,
"Oh, this is for kids."
And then they have their
moms angry at me and stuff.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So I'll slip a penis
joke every now and then.
(Garnt laughing)
- It'll be a perfectly kid-
- One frame.
- Yeah, a kid friendly
video and then you're like,
"Cock, cock, cock."
- It's like that scene in
Fight Club where they put
that one frame of a cock, and
nobody notices it. (laughs)
- It's like the Tyler Durden of YouTube.
- We don't wanna swear ever.
We don't wanna swear ever because-
- Do you ever curse in your videos?
- No, never because we could
spend a month on a video
and then have it demonetized
because you said fuck once.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So we don't swear, ever, ever.
- I'm too British for that.
- Yeah, I'm too Australian for that.
- Yeah but you can, you can
kind of get away with that
if you're like, "Oh, this
video only took me three days
to film, I can try-
- I don't wanna throw
away work just so I can't-
- Yeah, I still don't wanna throw away
three days worth of work.
- It's not as bad as a whole
month though, you know?
- The risk to reward is less, you know?
- "Oh, heck, man."
- "Oh, flipping heck."
- I think my nude model
video got demonetized,
but I was like, "Ah, fair enough."
I drew a dick and a butt,
and another dick and a butt.
- Wait, wait, so you're afraid to say fuck
because you get demonetized,
but you'll still slip in
a penis joke?
- You'll still draw a dick?
- When you do a drawing,
there's cheats you can do.
- What's the cheat?
- What, you put a face on it?
- What's the hack?
- You don't make it too detailed.
- No veins?
- You could slip in maybe one vein.
(all laugh)
But that's it.
- And you end the sentence with, "Man."
It's like, "This is just a dick, man."
- "Here's my dick, man."
- Youtube's like, "Damn, he's one of us."
- "I was gonna demonetize."
- "I was gonna demonetize but he's just
so friendly about it."
- But with a 2D animation, or
just Story Timers or whatever.
I think if you have a
team you'll maybe survive
and then most of them
will either get burnt out
or they're just like, "I'm done.
Let me move on."
- What do you think is the
path that most Story Time
animators take?
'Cause the path of a lot of AniTubers is-
- That's the thing.
That's the tough part.
For most part, the audience
only wants art or 2D.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So when they stray away from that path,
the audience lose interest.
So they're like, "I'm
not gonna, I don't care.
Whatever."
- I mean, but there's been a
couple of Story Time animators
who have still found success
in other avenues, right?
Obviously, maybe not
as massive as the peak,
but you know, there's a couple.
I can't name off names specifically.
- I think they're trying different things.
I think with YouTube,
you always have to try
different things.
You have to change everything.
I do that sometimes, and
then if I stray too much,
I'm like, "Okay, I'll just
do one video to reset it
and then I'll start to
stray again." (chuckles)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- If it's a full like
shift, completely away,
then that's how you'll
alienate your audience,
but if it's a gradual fade in.
I think that's the best way to do it.
- It's tricky though, because
since you only release
a video once or twice
or three times a month,
you can only slowly sway them.
It would take too long.
It would take like, a year
by the time you're done
with a slow progression.
- Did you have one video that blew up
or did crazy numbers?
- Oh, yeah, so yeah, when
I was in my basement dying
and jobless and my mom
was like, "Go get a job,
go get a job."
And I was like, "Ma,
I'm trying, I'm trying!"
Actually, I was about to quit on the video
which was called, "Nude models" Actually.
Yeah, Nude models.
- That one?
- That wasn't the one that blew up.
I was about to quit, and I told everybody.
My family members and everyone,
because I was feeling like
shit, I was depressed.
And everybody else was like,
if they mentioned the word "Job"
Near me, I would freak out.
(Joey laughs)
(Connor screams)
But yeah, basically, my
friend posted a on our/video,
my nude model video, and
it got the most up votes.
- Oh, okay.
- And then it blew up.
So then I went, I made another video
and then it snowballed and
it, and then that's how
I'm here today.
- [Joey] Oh, okay.
- What was the thing that
you told your friends
and family about the video fails?
What did you tell them?
- Oh, well, at the time it was,
it was always low views
because I had like what,
like 70 subs from,
he gave me like, 700 subs,
but that's not enough
to get going.
- So you were like, "If
I don't get 100K views,
I'm quitting."
What was the?
- [Daidus] Yeah, basically.
Oh, because if you do it
long enough, you're like,
"I can't do this anymore."
I have to get a real job
because it's already been
almost two years.
- So what were your views getting?
What kind of numbers were
you pulling in before that,
and then that video?
- Oh, like million, 2
million, 3 million, 4 million.
- That's what it got?
- I think it's like, 3 million, 5 million.
I don't fucking know.
- And before that you were getting what?
Like 10,000, 1,000?
- Oh, I was getting like 100.
- Wow.
- So it went from like 100 views.
- I actually, I went from
like, 700 subscribers
'cause of Joey, and then
I jumped up all the way
straight to 400K, and then-
- Oh my God.
- All these people on Twitter
were like, in my Dms, and I
was scared because I'm like,
"Are they gonna use me?
Are they gonna use me?"
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I closed myself off 'cause I'm like,
"No, no, no, no, stop,
stay away, stay away."
Because the Story Time community were,
it was built off collabing a lot.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I felt like I only want
to collab when I really.
- Know the person.
- Know the person, yeah.
- But when you're starting
off with collabing
right off the bat, you
know, that's what they want
in their mind.
It puts me off, I'm like.
- Yeah 'cause I've
never had the experience
just blowing up overnight like that.
- It's scary.
I mean it's cool.
It's awesome.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Every emotion, "Actually no,
it was fucking terrifying."
- I was a lot more cynical
back then, but now I'm just,
I'm chilling.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You're just vibing.
- Cynical, how so?
You're like, "They're all gonna leave me.
They don't wanna watch."
- No, cynical as in
like, "Are you using me?"
- Oh, what, other YouTubers?
- [Daidus] Yeah, yeah.
I feel bad though 'cause, you know,
some people hit me up.
- [Connor] You push people away?
- I push them away and I'm
like, "Oh, but he's..."
I learned later, like a
year or two later, I'm like,
"You know, that guy's pretty cool.
Fuck, I ruined that."
- Yeah, but I don't think
it's bad to be cautious,
because especially after
you blow up overnight
and suddenly everyone's
in your DMs and like,
"Well, you guys weren't
talking to me before
and now everyone's up in my DMs."
- Yes.
- And that's why I rarely
ever, if ever collab.
- It's like the people, you
know, who are on TV, you know,
for like, 30 seconds, and
then their third cousin
suddenly calls them, and it's like, "Hey!"
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
- It's sus.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
- Very sus.
- Especially in the YouTube community,
there are definitely cool
guys and cool girls out there,
but there are some, huh?
- Cool girls and guys.
- Cool girls and guys?
- But there are definitely some that are
definitely just not.
- [Joey] There for the clout.
- Yeah, there for the clout.
- For me it's like, I have
to meet them in person.
- Oh yeah, of course.
- Yeah.
I mean, that helps an awful lot.
I honestly found a lot of
the internet bullshit drops
the moment you meet someone.
- That was you, was a black Butler.
You were into black Butler at the time.
- What'd you mean?
- You were in a Black Butler ring.
(Joey laughs)
- What's that got to do with me?
- You were in Black Butler ring.
- Okay.
- That's when I first met you.
At the FAKKU party, you
were black Butlering.
- What does that mean?
- Wait, wait, wait.
- That's not a verb.
That's not a verb.
- Are you saying that
Connor was better in person
or worse in person?
- I love Connor in person, yeah.
- But you didn't online?
- [Daidus] Huh?
- What did you think about me online?
You thought I was an asshole?
- No, I didn't.
I didn't even know who you were.
- Wow.
(Joey laughs)
- "I don't even know who you are."
- "You're not even worth my breath, dude."
- No, Emily introduced you to me.
You and Emily were friends
from the beginning.
And Emily told me you was a cool guy.
And I was like, "Oh, sweet."
And then when you talked to me,
it's like sweet butter in my ears, dude.
(all laughing)
- I'm feeling these emotions.
- I was like, "This is very nice."
(all laughing)
Actually, there's a story
at that FAKKU party.
- Oh, okay.
- I was with a bunch of
friends, and I was drunk, right?
- Yeah, of course.
- Emily got too drunk
and then she ended up
throwing up outside.
- Yeah.
- And all my friends
ditched me because I went to the bathroom.
- Yeah.
- And I came out
and I was like-
- To poop?
- No, no, no.
- [Connor] He was cleaning all the vomit.
- Yeah. (laughing)
- I was peeing.
- Okay.
- But I went out, and I was like,
"Where'd all my friends go?"
And so then I was like,
"I guess I'll force myself
to mingle with the AnimeTubers,
which were you guys,
and that's when this drunk
fuck comes over there.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But that was my experience.
I got ditched, so I was forced to...
- To mingle around.
- We wouldn't have met
if your friends didn't ditch you.
- Yeah, basically.
- You were saying the
story like I did something.
You were saying the story
like, "Ah, let me tell you
about Connor" And then you just didn't.
- No, Connor was my drinking buddy.
I kept trying to get him
drunk, I was like, "Here."
I'm that kind of drunk, I'm like,
"I'm gonna buy you a drink.
I'm gonna buy you a drink.
I'll buy you another drink."
- It was fun, it was
fun, it was a good time.
Your friends were really nice as well.
- Yeah, they were,
yeah, they were awesome.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- Why did you have to slant the words?
Like, "They were, awesome."
- Is there some beef I don't know about?
- I'm sorry, I got Windows
98 processor in my brain.
- That was like, "How
do I compliment again?
Awesome."
- That's a positive word.
- Conventions are just fun vibes, man.
Everyone's made an effort
to come out, you know?
Everyone's looking for a good time.
- It's very fun.
- It's just like,
everyone's in their best mood, hopefully.
Normally, it's super great.
- And normally intoxicated because-
- [Connor] That helps as
well, that helps as well.
- 'Cause I remember, I felt so
bad 'cause when you came here
and I was just like, "Oh,
nice to finally meet you."
And I was just like,
"Oh, we've met before."
I was like, "We have?"
- Garnt at the FAKKU party
was just, here's his beer,
he's just like this.
(men laughing)
- Call him out, call him out, dude.
- Bro, I was just trying
my best to look sober
even though I was just like,
"I'm dying inside, man."
- I think Garnt had hit
that, you know that point
where you're so drunk where
you just look sober again?
I think that's what Garnt was.
- I thought he was sober
too, he was just like,
"Nah, it's cool, man."
- He was definitely drunk.
- I was at that point of drunkness
where I was just existing
and I'm just like, "What is
going on right now, man?"
- 100% of his brain was just vibing.
That's what it was.
It was just like, "Yeah, I
am here, I am also here."
- Yeah, I barely remember
the FAKKU party that year,
I'm gonna be honest. (laughs)
But yeah, so it's good to have you here.
- We can interact in the flesh again.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Finally I have friends again.
I lost all my friends in the States.
- Yeah.
- So are you completely settled in now?
- You like Murray show?
- [Joey] Yeah?
- The Murray show where they're like,
"You are not the final."
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I wasn't the one that cheated,
but I was in a group that
one cheated on the others,
and then there's a kid
involved and I had to,
I had to leave the group.
I was like, "Oh, this sucks"
Because I've known these guys
for my whole life, and all
of a sudden this Murray show
hits me and I'm like,
"Well shit, I just lost
all my friends, fuck."
- [Joey] Oh, damn.
- You know where there's a change?
- What kinda story is this?
- Look, I don't wanna go in too detailed
because I don't wanna blast on them.
I don't wanna blast on them.
- The friend group was kind of toxic?
- It's not so much, I think it's just
something happened, right?
- Two people just did not very.
- Good things?
- Good things, yeah.
And I'm like, "I can't do this anymore."
I'm like, I told them, I'm like,
"I'm gonna have to cut it off.
I'm just gonna go."
- "I'm leaving the States."
- So that kind of made
my basement dwelling
even more intense.
- Right, right, right, okay.
- That was like, I don't
know, three years ago
or something.
- Oh, that long ago?
- Three years ago.
- Sounds like before COVID.
- You told me this story previously.
- Yeah, before COVID.
- But I thought it was recent.
- Yeah, I thought it was
just happened during COVID,
and it just made, yeah, it
just made your isolation
even worse during COVID.
I didn't realize it was
even just before COVID.
- Well, my friends, they're
all gamers, back in the States.
So we never hung out, ever.
And then when I do be like,
"Hey, you want to go?"
I could tell they kind of don't want to.
They'd just rather stay and play a game.
Which is fine, but you know,
this is, but here it's like,
now I'm like, "Oh, hang
out with everyone."
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'm like, "All right, let's go.
Let's go watch this shitty movie called"
What's that fucking movie?
- Doctor Strange?
- Doctor Strange and the
multiverse, whatever the fuck.
That movie was garbage, my God.
- See?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You were right, you were right.
- I said this a few episodes ago.
- Oh, yeah.
- Are you totally settled down
now in your new place then?
Are you still building
furniture like the last time
we met?
- I still have one or
two furnitures to build.
- It never ends.
Honestly, it never ends.
- Bro, I would move in,
and then within a week
I'd be working.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- I moved in, gotta do this,
gotta do this, gotta do that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Gotta get your residence.
You have to go to the,
what's that residence?
- Ward office.
What did you call it?
- It was resident something?
- Oh, the resident certificate, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Or residents card?
- Resident office?
- No.
- You gotta tell them you're moving.
- Yeah.
- It reminded me of
the DMV.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like the ward office, right?
- It definitely does, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You gotta do that and
then, and then that.
- Yeah, it's a lot of paperwork involved.
- And then it's in Japanese so
you're like, "How does this?
How do I?"
- [Joey] What side is up?
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- What do I sign?
- Yeah, and then, I think
when I wear my mask outside,
people think I'm Japanese
so then they'll try to speak
Japanese to me and I'm like,
"Uh..." (Speaks Japanese)
- The neck starts to move.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It is an advantage but a
disadvantage at the same time.
- It gets a lot easier.
Ever since I moved, I've only
been to the ward office once.
I rarely have to go.
- Yeah, setting up your life
here takes a lot of effort,
but luckily you're getting
able to get a lot of help
and it's almost done, and
then once it's set up,
it's so easy.
It's like breezing.
- Yeah, GeexPlus made it very easy.
Very easy.
- [Connor] Damn, thanks, man.
- Shout out to GeexPlus.
- [Joey] Shout out GeexPlus.
- Shout out to us being
the beta testers. (laughs)
- If it's not, you're
just lying to someone.
"Okay, go over there today."
- Definitely helps.
- Yeah, that definitely helps.
- Yeah, what else do you have to do still?
Do you know?
- What else do we have to do?
Yeah, I need a computer chair, Meilyne.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- My wooden chair hurts my ass.
- Are you back working now?
'Cause you've been here for like a month.
- I wanna work but my goddam wooden chair
hurts my ass so much in
front of my computer.
- You're like a princess.
You can't work unless the
conditions are perfect.
- I need my computer chair.
- "It's my computer chair, I need it."
- "Bring me my omega chair.
This instance."
That's good though that you're settled in.
But you know, you're
still on that, you know,
furniture building phase.
- No, I'm ready to work, dude.
I'm feeling it.
- Has the holiday phase ended?
'Cause I remember when
I first moved to Japan,
I'm just like, "This just
feels like a holiday right now.
I'm not gonna lie.
Do I really need to work?
I don't know."
- It has finally ended because
we finally got, you know,
the sofa, the TV.
Before then we couldn't even sit anywhere.
We'd have to lie on the floor.
We bought these, what are those?
- [Connor] Futons.
- Futons?
- Yeah, yeah.
- We slept on that for like,
three weeks or something.
- Oh my God.
- We were waiting for our bed.
And then we had no couch, so
when we get up, there's like-
- [Joey] Nowhere to sit.
- We could never rest.
And then the only way to rest
is your wooden kitchen chair,
which hurts your ass.
- I wanna say, you're the only person
I think I've ever seen who has
built a PC worse than Joey.
- Really?
- Oh, thank God.
- You helped me a lot,
thank you.
- Daidus was like, "I'm gonna build a PC.
Is it hard?" And I'm like, "No,
no, no, it should be fine."
And I've struggled before in the past.
It's kinda hard, but you can do it.
- [Daidus] It's hard.
- I've been there.
I've been there.
- [Daidus] Thank you.
- One day Daidus texts me
and he's like, "Connor, SOS."
Literally, SOS.
(Joey laughs)
He's like, "I need help."
And I'm like, "Why, what's wrong?"
He's like, "Oh, the PC,
I think I've broken it,
or it won't work.
I don't know what to do."
- [Daidus] Yeah, the processor.
- I go over to his house, right?
First thing I see is that
nothing is plugged in correctly.
- The wires scared of me.
- It is, it's daunting.
- Yeah!
I'm like, "Where plugs in to where?"
- I get it.
- And so I find one problem, and I'm like,
"Okay, let's fix this then."
And as I fix it, I find another problem.
And then I'm like, "Okay,
well let's fix it."
And then as I'm gonna
fix this, I found out
the motherboard isn't even screwed in.
- Oh, it's just sitting there?
- [Garnt] It's just floating.
- [Daidus] It was four
screwed in and then the ends.
- So the motherboard typically is like,
nine screws, right?
For a normal sized one.
He'd only screwed in six, and
one half of the motherboard.
- [Daidus] It wouldn't let me!
- So it was just kinda flapping.
- You could flip it.
- Oh, man.
- And it was lifted up, and I'm like,
"Bro, you got one month
out of this PC at best."
And so we have to take
out the whole thing.
- Even I know that you need
to screw in the motherboard.
- Yeah, okay, but it was hanging up,
so I thought it was like,
"Oh, it's a different type of case.
Maybe it's supposed to hang like that."
But then Connor came in and
he put a little washer in it
and then increased the size of the screw.
And I was like, "Oh.
That's how you screw it in."
- I just couldn't believe it.
I was like, "This PC, you
know, it's gonna last-"
- It was a tiny case too.
- Was it because you were
watching every tutorial
at times two speed, so he
missed the part where they were
screwing it in.
He's like, "Oh, I guess it just
screws in like that, right?"
- No, okay, the problem
with watching tutorials
is that they're like, I
have a different motherboard
and a different graphic
card to a different screw.
- Because you were building
it for Emily, right?
So Emily wanted a pink
case and this case was-
- [Daidus] Was tiny.
- Was garbage.
It's probably the worst PC
case I've ever worked with.
The graphics card had one
millimeter of clearance.
- Oh my God.
- To get in the case.
- Was that the only pink
case you could find in Japan?
- Yeah, I think so.
- Oh, okay.
- Well, pink anything game
related is always not cool.
- It is a miracle it all fit.
And then, there's no room in the case,
and he texts me, he's like,
"Why are the fans so loud?"
I'm like, "'Cause there's no air."
- It's hyperventilating.
- Of course, you got a 3080 in there
and like one bag of air.
(Joey laughs)
- Hey, but it's fans.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It works now I guess.
But, yeah, I know that feel.
It's scary.
I guess, you know, since
it is your first time
moving to basically a
completely different country.
Is there anything, do you
have a bucket list of things
you wanna do still?
I'm sure you've ticked off
all the food stuff, right?
for the most part?
- For the most part.
- An you know,
like kombini and shit.
But is there anything you wanna like,
"I wanna go to certain place or I wanna do
this certain thing I
couldn't do in the US."
Or you just trying to-
- I haven't been to Onsen yet, Onsen?
- Hell yeah.
We've gotta take you to Onsen, man.
- [Joey] Boys night.
Boys day.
- Boys trip, let's go.
- We're gonna see each other's dicks.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You'll literally get over it.
- What is that look?
You're like, "Okay, master."
- You'll get over it in like, 15 seconds.
- We've seen each other's dick many times.
- I'm down, I'm ready.
- I remember when I took
these boys to an Onsen
the first time.
We were just like, "All
right, let's just look at
each other's dicks.
- Yeah.
- Just get it out of the way.
- We just slap it around, you know?
- Yeah, just wet noodle
fight for a little bit,
you're like, "All right, we're good."
No one's hard, we're good.
- We go to the bidet, wash
our balls and all that shit.
- We've been to do a fan
meet up, it's no different.
- Play daggers.
(Garnt laughs)
- No, but yeah, I think
you'll really, I mean,
you love taking baths already, right?
So you'll fucking love the Onsen.
- Yeah, it's just like
taking a bath with your bros.
In a massive bath tub.
- I'm down, bro.
I'm down.
(Joey laughs)
- It sucks though because
we can't take you to the one
I took these guys to.
- Yeah.
- It just closed down now.
- [Daidus] What?
- There's another one somewhere else,
but it was really far away.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah.
- In Tokyo?
- Not, just outside of Tokyo.
- Oh, okay, okay.
- I was gonna ask, do you
have any piece of advice
for anyone who does wanna move abroad?
Anything you've learned on this thing
that you'd wanna share with people?
- Because you, more than
anyone else I've met,
has just jumped into the deep end,
without even dipping your toes in at all.
- Well, that's just
because of GeeXPlus, right?
- No, but I mean, you know, not gonna lie,
I probably wouldn't have
the balls to just be like,
"Yeah, I'm just gonna move to this country
I've never been to.
And just start living there."
That takes a lot.
- I think you just have to be done.
You're like, "I'm done."
I gotta go.
- Done or dumb?
- Done.
- Oh, done.
I was like, "Just be dumb?"
- Just be dumb.
- Don't think.
- Just be like, "I want something new."
And also, it's Japan, bro.
- I mean, even if you visit,
it's still hard to get the feel
for how it is to actually live there.
Visiting Japan and living here
is two completely different experiences.
- But you wouldn't know that either.
- You'll never get that.
I'm joking.
- Maybe that's a blessing, I don't know.
- Yeah, yeah, maybe it is, maybe it is.
I don't know.
- I enjoy it a lot.
I have no regrets.
- I was worried when
that, when I was like,
"Yeah, you should come
over" And you're like,
"Yeah, let's do it."
I was like, "Oh my God,
what if he hates it?"
- I was really worried that
you were just gonna get
the biggest culture shock of your life,
because you've never experienced
anything like this before,
but seems like you're
really having a good time.
- 'Cause for a lot of people it's like,
it's so far off from
what they're used to that
it's not cool for them.
- But that's what makes it
fun though.
- Right, but a lot of people
can't take that, right?
A lot of people are like,
"No, this is too much."
- Yeah, "This is too much."
- For real?
- Yeah.
- Because I think there's a lot of people-
- You're like, "What, what?!
That's possible?"
- Because there's a lot
of people who are like,
"Yeah, I love traveling."
But then when they actually
travel they, you know,
end up going to McDonald's,
and they try and seek comfort
in a different country,
in a different culture.
- I think, well having,
you know, people I know.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It helps immensely.
- Oh yeah, yeah, absolutely, absolutely.
- If you guys weren't
here, it'd just be like,
it would be a struggle.
I'd be like, "What do I do?"
- "Back in the basement then, I guess."
- But in Japan this time.
(all laughing)
- Very, very fortunate.
- Yeah, 'cause even small
things, like I remember,
I've met plenty of
people who are just like,
"Man, the food's here amazing."
And you meet them like a
month in , they're like,
"Do people eat rice with every meal?
Every meal?"
- I love that stuff.
I don't think I'll ever
get tired of Japanese food.
- When I came here on vacation,
I got really tired of Japanese food.
- [Daidus] Really?
- When I lived here, I didn't.
I don't know why.
- I think maybe it's because
while you're on vacation,
you were seeking out Japanese food, right?
Because you were kind of
in that mentality of like,
"Well, I don't get the opportunity
to have these foods, so."
- Even the fried chicken didn't
quite have the greasiness.
- I do miss some American shit.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh yeah, yeah, of course.
- That's gonna happen.
- I think that's the cool thing about,
especially Tokyo, right?
Is that there's literally
every type of cuisine
available out there, right?
- It is pretty crazy.
- Yeah.
There's very few cuisines
that I'm just like,
"I can't get that here."
Maybe I'm craving a specific
dish that I can't get here,
but for the most part,
you can get anything here
in terms of good food.
- And good service.
- Literally robots.
Literally robots.
- "They're not human,
I don't respect them.
They give me my food."
- Their soul is gone.
Like, actually.
- I'm not sure about that.
- I don't know about that.
- Oh my God.
- But yeah, anyway, that's
been today's episode
of Trash Taste, I think.
- Where can they find you, Daidus?
Where do you wanna shout out?
- Oh, YouTube, Daidus.
- YouTube.com/Daidus.
- Twitter?
- Twitter, Daidus, and
then it has an underscore.
- Yeah.
- OTL.
He has a guy on the-
- On his knees, yeah.
- And then I think my
Twitch is Daidus_otl also.
- Okay.
- 'Cause someone took Daidus
and then on Twitter someone took Daidus.
And then on I Instagram is Daidus_art.
I don't know why it's different.
It just is.
- Mix it up, spice it up.
- At least you got the Daidus, you know?
That's what's important, yeah.
- Thanks so much for coming.
- Thank you so much.
- But hey, look at all
these patrons though.
- I mean, we're gonna be
hanging out a lot more anyway.
- Yeah, we're gonna be doing stuff.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- When you're done with your wedding.
- Yeah, when I'm coming.
Literally you and Emily come in, I'm like,
"All right, guys, I'm off now, I'm off"
- It's like, "Be gone."
- Yeah.
- But hey, if you'd like
to support the show,
go over to our Patreon.
Patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter,
send us some memes
on the subreddit, and
if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
- They hate your face?
- [Joey] Yeah.
(Daidus and Garnt laugh)
- Is that a thing you've been saying?
- Yeah.
- You watch Trash Talk!
- No, he missed out
because it's times two.
- Yeah, yeah.
- When I get to the Patreon part, pause.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- Back button.
- Piece of shit, Daidus.
Get out of here.
- All right, see you guys next time, bye.
(relaxing music)
(music continues)